une production du studio sfr vient nous
sans filtre le podcast on parle de ce
qu'ont vécu nos invités date site super
content avec moi d'une plante si vous
voulez louer le studio sfr ont le loup
il sa vie avec l'équipement avec les
techniciens
ça vient avec tout en fait ce que vous
avez ce que vous avez besoin vous avez
juste besoin de venir vous asseoir
autour de la table puis de créer votre
contenu apprécié on s'occupe du reste
vous voulez plus d'infos là dessus allé
au studio sfr ainsi à cette semaine
d'hommes cette semaine une diction
vraiment fascinante passionnante avec un
un homme du nom de roger godbout qui
professeur au département de psychiatrie
de merci montréal est aussi psychologue
et directeur de laboratoire technique du
sommeil hôpital en santé mentale rivière
des prairies suez nord de l'île de
marianne en titre on a parlé du sommeil
c'est de comprendre c'est quoi pourquoi
condor la science derrière aussi
l'insomnie comment trouver des astuces
pour améliorer la qualité de son sommeil
pour pouvoir dormir pouvoir a presque
fonctionné dans la vie on a parlé des
grèves aussi la ratification le qu'est
ce qui se passe dans cerveau quand on
rêve c'était vraiment super intéressante
je pense que ça va
toucher tout le monde que deux mandats
ça va servir à tout le monde pour
essayer d'améliorer son sommet yes juste
avant d'aller écouter la conversation on
va les remercier nos sponsors sans qui
rien de tout ça serait possible
aujourd'hui on vous parle de flip inpi
clip mpix est une application c'est un
réseau social pour encourager les
commerces lequel on le sait que c'est
important le 6 important de se soutenir
et d'encourager une autre notre prochain
notre voisin qu'un commerce que que
philippe mpix a fait ça en fait on peut
partager nos découvertes locales nous
nos boutiques nous restent avant tout
tout commerçant fait important des
photos sur ce réseau social
et les gens qui font qu'ils vous suivent
vont découvrir ces endroits là et
inversement les gens que vous suivez sur
cette application sociale découvrir
leurs coups de coeur
et quant à être mieux finalement les
commerces le coach proche du chef du psp
si vous partagez votre cas vous
accumulez des flips social en fait qui
est une monnaie virtuelle a même
l'application qui vous permet d'échanger
ce compte des offres exclusives dans des
commerces locaux fait qu'en plus de
faire donner de la publicité aux
commerces locaux vous-même recevrez un
petite compensation qui vous permettent
d'encourager un autre commerce local
donc tout ça c'est 360 c'est vraiment
vraiment roth
moi j'ai découvert que merckx locaux je
vais vous parler de cette petite
découverte dans notre quartier à verdon
chercher un café où est ce que je
pouvais aller prendre les gants il aller
prendre une marche pas ce qui est en
effet un confinement faut pas sortir
emmené je voulais aller prendre des
marches donc j'ai découvert le bigot
saint lô à verdun qui est un genre de
café où est ce qu'ils vendent des sanwi
ce bébé gaulle qui sont extraordinaires
j'ai découvert ça grâce à flipper pic
fait que sans ça je n'aurais pas
découvert simple maintenant c'est mon
café de quartier que j'encourage à
pratiquement tous les jours
vous pouvez vous demander l'application
utilisé un code promo lorsque vous allez
ouvrir votre compte si le sf locale ça
vous vous donnez 10 mille flep locale à
partir de 15000 il ya déjà des offres
exclusives donc vous avez un bon bout de
chemin fait fait qu'aller faire sur pied
merci la gagne des plus belles piques
d'encourager les commerces locaux
oui le paquet de cette semaine est
présentée par emma point ces acquis et
une plateforme québécoise d'assurance
vie en ligne vous le savez ou sans fil
podcast on commence à se questionner sur
ce qu'on veut avoir des enfants ce
qu'est la famille s'en vient et on
commence à penser
advenant que qui nous arrive quelque
chose on veut pas laisser nos proches
dans le pétrin c'est pour ça que 20
minutes seulement vous allez vous pouvez
avoir accès à l'assurance vie pour vos
besoins
mais si vous savez pas exactement quels
sont vos besoins mais que vous savez que
vous avez besoin d'assurance vie qui ont
déconseillé en ligne qui vont vous aider
à choisir le port fait pour vous
la beauté des mots poids c'est ainsi que
les prix sont abordables bien en plus
c'est super simple ça se fait ce pas
rapidement et aucun examen médical qui
requis et ça se fait 100% en ligne
chaque fois chez vous un pyjama farce à
partir de votre téléphone tout en un où
parler un conseiller et un qu'ils
minutes ça peut être réglé en une as
envie on a l'esprit tranquille non plus
vaquer à notre vie sans aucun trac c'est
le genre d'affaires une assurance vie qu
on n'y pense pas jusqu'à temps qu'ils
aient quelque chose qui arrive pile du
fait pensez-y maintenant surtout avec
une compagnie québécoise qui rend ce
samedi même merci la gagne demain
pointer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur de boulsa tourner c'est parti
merci beaucoup d'être là on a déjà
commencé à parler de plaintes a fort
justement qu'on rentre en ondes et
écouter le sommeil c'est un sujet qui
touche tout le monde
c'est un sujet universel qui est tout le
monde doit dormir dans sa vie puis je
savoir on pourrait lancer sur toutes les
pistes mais je savoir avant qu'on qu'on
a dans le plus spécifique
est ce que la science du sommet une
science qui est encore en évolution
rapide est ce qu'on apprend encore
énormément sur le sommeil
oui on a un attrait beaucoup parce que
sa voix dans différentes directions
puyau un ancien que c'est tout a dit
déjà de balancier d'envoi du très très
fondamentale ou très très clinique du
trait biochimie coûterait
comportementale qui se promène comme ça
et puis dans un autre axe la technique
comme un con comme un con qu'on calcule
le sommeil c'est quoi les variables
technologie compare les équipements soit
ça varie énormément leur entrée de
l'orgie ce qu'on utilise comme outil
pour caractériser sommeil depuis 1900
soit ils ont commencé alors ce soir
d'aller dans d'autres façons
complètement par sa voix avec la même
façon qu on observe deux semaines
recherche fondamentale c'est comme tous
les domaines c'est de même c'est comme
c'est un bon rapport sans nommer dans la
demande d'apple dans calais j'en faisais
des petits bonhommes sont accrocheurs cl
d'eau moyenne house a confirmé
comprennent pas ce nom par savais pas
que les us orthez en tête telle façon
que perçoit la profondeur puis quelqu'un
soit une profondeur si tu géométriques
match minutes et personnages qui sont la
peinture transférer sow puis ces années
de la science s'est transféré à d'autres
choses
le point de signer c'est pareil titre
fin d'études isuppli personnage là mais
même à forcer rendre compte qu'on avait
des milliers de cellules perçoivent le
vert contre le rouge nicolas comté le
coup l'aviron qui exploite et ça c'est
sa compagne tout en sciences c'est
pareil pareil on voit développé des
fibres optiques qui nous promet depuis
des dizaines et des dizaines d'années
maintenant on les remet dans le cerveau
on envoie un jeu de lumières de telle
couleur qu'on a effecté des cellules
avec le drs qui réagit à deux longueurs
non là on peut faire arrêter la cellule
de fonctionner ou augmenter son
fonctionnement on voit que ses fesses le
copain
dans ce jeu sommeil l'alimentation
n'importe quoi quand le sommeil comme
tous les domaines ça avance énormément
beaucoup puis comme toujours on à face
que l'étude est que les petits
changements
ça nous impressionne pas beaucoup quatre
tourteaux regarde le disais que ça va
radio là le chemin parcouru en à bouger
pas mal d'accès évolue beaucoup beaucoup
dans beaucoup de directions pour une
petite communauté de chercheurs qui a
humilié lors c'est pas des congrès le
livret chercheurs les touristes des
frais parce qu'ils font des congrès
soeur beaucoup aurientis sûr attirer la
famille serra qui plus est haute et d'un
poster un signe sa réplique que ces
hôtels prochainement c'est normal
l'opération commerciale ya peut-être
saint mleux six mille chercheurs je
dirais dans les congés ou jet skis et
beaucoup beaucoup en neurosciences en
général c'est 35 mille 40 milliards dix
ans c'est pareil c'est 40 milles avant
moi quand j'ai commencé à lui verser gt3
puis trois semaines j'ai tous les
papiers que certains ce sommet je le
prenais pas tant de matérialisation soit
26 fascicule par la malle qui tangue
avec des banques et se soumettant des 28
articles
la star si vos besoins je travaille cela
fait un mois de chercher ce qu'il faut
obtenir une extraordinaire quand ce mail
il y aussi des mythes qui se fond qui se
défend laksaci du changement aussi tout
le temps est-ce qu'il faut dormir tant
de pouvoir tout ce qu'on doit dans mes
temps dans la calanque en même temps de
nommer atteint large calandre cas là
qu'on doit se coucher
si tu dangereux d'être somme nabeul tout
seul sachant que sachant que ça change
quand on regarde loin derrière qu'on
rencontre en voyage on peut voir la
trajectoire on vous attendait de revenir
et c'est son problème ce n'est pas un
sujet que ce soit qu'on sait plus
pencher là dessus il ya pas une plus
grosse communauté chercheurs pour
quelque chose qui est aussi fondamental
et universel est important puisqu'elle
un pack aussi grand sur toutes les
hautes sphères de la vie
ce patient ce qui est jeune la science
science se met ça commençait des années
5 à peu près quand on a découvert une
sorte de sommeil sommet dix ans de
grandes files le sommet l'un qui se met
paradoxal on disait floué slip rapide
mouvement c'est sur celle ci pour la le
jeu aussi de sortir des c'est pour la
consolidation de la mémoire pis si le
moment où est-ce qu'on rêve oui parfait
on continue sur trop où exactement en
somme
et puis à narguer sont au village
l'opérationnel au sommet personne ne m
mais c'est sommeil lancé tu le sais le
deep sleep là dedans et lycées dans le
sommeil lent que ça fait partie
c'est ça des gens en disant un stade 1 2
3 4 c'est plus en plus profond me
sommeil paradoxal ernst lieb ce soit
mais qu'on passe mais moins figé jacky
maillet moins profond parce que nos
zones cérébrales sont comme sont
réveillés sorte de tout cela est
complètement atonique hatton est comme
paralysée
on est paralysée on rit on laissait
vraiment actif qui sans dormir cet actif
des cellules sont responsables ont fait
baisser propriétaire s'appelle pierre
lumbi sa baisse en pré commande famille
paupières d'une commande qui a
occasionné par des commandes qui descend
ça brime analyse tous les nouveaux
neurones puis qu'on est paralysée sont
certains muscles le créateur a passé de
laisser respirer pendant yad'autres qui
fonctionne aussi aux yeux bougent à tous
et direction dont le nom en anglais dit
les choses comme cela fait que ça
s'était découvert en 1955
plusieurs proches y faire en sorte de
soleil puis park à 20 sont déjà allés
dans les stades
1 2 3 4 sommeil lent les pilleurs des
avait semé paradoxale du budget puis les
ont cérébrale et est tout un art bing
bang sonique non pas que les affaires
sont ma maison elle est servie pensant
veau puis on se poserait problème et du
sujet bon ben natan purement mais des
culottes pour ce vote c'est fini jusqu'à
ce qu'ils découvrent ça pour dire c'est
un autre match a été découvert par
hasard comme ça rique c'était un jeune
médecin résident
qu'ils agissent très sommaires d'enfants
dont son petit go et puis il tend la
boucle son boss alors son directeur de
travail de recherche puis l'enfant
dormait pour bout d'une heure et demi à
peu près les yeux bougent pile il dit
lisons cérébrale bosseuse bommel va les
réveiller tôt touati je vois les
voitures trouvera l'habillement aux
analyses maintenant ils dormaient depuis
leur mobile puis quand il ya compté
rights watch
cinq syndicats ces qui se passe ici ils
ont aussi pendant deux trois ans publie
le papier cash à 90 minutes on se met à
bouger de sun puis les deux revues de
rennes on imagine sont brisées et du
fait que ma thèse en france et d'un
artefact turc conflit par le possible
c'était le début de la parade en même
temps en france et un chercheur actuelle
amène gens d'affaires justel tonus
musculaire qui a découvert plus d'un
français sur dix shows ses terres et cet
anesthésique la mort puis s'est rendu
compte que son eau chaude dans un talus
suite la baisse est plus observés çà
train de mourir ben oui pas comment que
six ports secs sur cette centrale qui
paralysait autour du spiral stacked il
me semble c'est sommeil paradoxal d
unibook de cerveaux que donne dix ans
serait pas rapide qui était paralysée
c'est en tout cas pas de rêver ça un gta
iv
donc ça peut être pas depuis longtemps
ce qui fait que les milieux qui forment
des chercheurs côté promis congrès
l'ostéoporose possible
les gens formaient donc tous deux
étudiants par année puis sur un 10 n y
en a un qui restaient dans le domaine
axa 38 ans boom est vraiment avec les
apnées du sommeil déposant ce père at
war qu'on fait le camp fait trop souvent
n'est pas bien s'étaient découvert primo
je m'étais identifier des années 1960 et
quelques sons des 500 comme ça et puis
les intérêts du monde ça attire du monde
pilotes c'était le phénomène parfait
pour être et au temps des cliniciens des
médecins que déjà le comportement par
son trait saône en un jour que des
électrophysiologistes s'intéresse aux
hôpitaux
puis elle a donné un bon caster des
congrès sommeil c'est la moitié ses
actifs du ray avec des compagnies
d'apnée des compagnies machine bah t'as
pas tendres puis l'autre moitié ça va
être d'autres choses
ce que dans un grand créateur un tract
clinique une traque recherche humaine un
tract recherche animale par exemple que
tu choisis tes détracteurs de tranches
moins dissipée la date taxi donc
relativement jeune structure portante de
charlotte gastaut mais le symbole mais
en élargissant temps car les vrais de
vrais chercheurs techniciens et les
touristes des gens qui viennent pour
deux ou trois ans les grands labos qui
vont travailler là dessus parce que
question à eux qui veulent vérifier en
sommeil qui vont ils vont travailler
là-dessus parle de trois hommes se
trouvaient pu approfondir
est ce que je me trompe en disant que
pour la générale le public
le public attelage il ya un intérêt
marqué pour le semaine dans les
dernières années un intérêt pour
l'optimisation du sommeil
ah oui plutôt sur tout ça pour dire non
la première phase on a formulé sa page
pas certain que les gens s'intéressent
tant que les médias plus les médias plus
les vulgarisateurs tous sommes de plus
en plus soin des petits reportages à la
télé au changement d'heure je me fait
bombarder comme tous mes collègues
s'affairent le par contre de vérifier la
qualité sont sommés à soi même ouf ça
fait partie du sel qu'on dit faillite de
prendre des mesures de son propre état
son corps sa forme son pour sa
température tout l'homme puisse jamais
rentrer là dedans un peu plus compliqué
la mesure est pas comme le pouls c'est
plus compliqué un petit peu ce qui fait
que la plupart de ces équipements alors
démontrent par exemple pour la bague
d'une banque comme ce qui se dit et se
poser faire ça ça prend pour chad st
juste eu la flamme à température
température corporelle puis
techniquement ça me dit
puis possiblement que c'est pas
extrêmement précis mais samedi maison de
sommeil donc on va en parler là on en
parlera tout à fait intéressante vous le
montrez leur apporte au rapport m
peut-être ou peut-être plus tard mais
ouais je serais curieux d'avoir la vidéo
parce que ça c'est cdcc des équipements
qui permettent de mesurer certains des
aspects du sommeil ça donne une bonne
idée de deux choses importantes par
rapport à ça c'est design au stick pour
un trouble du sommeil est pas bon 0 ça
ressemble pas aux mesures comprennent
normalement puis je poserai présentant
deux compagnies ce projet olympique de
la vente
moi c'est ça marche pas on voit pas
innocemment par contre c'est fiable pour
une même personne d'une fois à l'autre
moi c'est ça si depuis un mois de repos
des oui ma bague melody et ah ça c'est
vrai ça marche puis ça c'est super le
fun parce que les gens s'intéressent à
leur sommeil en train de conscience puis
moi je me rends compte dépit que je
prends plus d'alcool de soi ou que vous
cacher mon jogging trop tard le soir ou
que pourquoi je dors mon idée je le vois
bay otsuki joueurs achetés sont disposés
comme prendre son poids le matin j'ai
pris deux kilos vrai choix attention ça
mais j'en avais quand j -pd un frein
de l'alcool je le vois tout de suite son
mât bagad me le dis tout de suite dans
la nuit il ya aucune façon que je que je
mente pas complet c'est la température
du corps qui montre ce qu'est ce qui se
passe quand comprendre l'alcool et des
règlements d'abord on peut savoir la
même atteint 4 ans se réveille quand nos
possibilités
généralement c'est pas beaucoup de repos
tant que ça ça change le contrôle la
température qu'on à sa cause du petit
réveil constant dans son esprit une
certaine d'autres parce que pour
certaines personnes faibles doses of est
excitant un peu plus ça va être calme
mais fois que ses calmants ça peut nous
endormir parce que on dit je t'aime
applicables pour y expliquer ça vous
tente pas comment marquer puis il peut
dormir
de fait on n'a pas donc ça sert baisse
le niveau d'éveil
si vous déviez bas et c'est le sommet
peut embarquer pu prendre la place c'est
toujours un jour les deux et puis quand
on prend la cote donc ça fait ça on
s'endort mello il faut qu'on tende
hormis la machine fonctionne pas
normalement contrôler la température qui
devrait normalement baisser parce que
toutes tes reproches sarin pour nous
mettre en mode hibernation
quand on tombe endormi sa belle sa
température on respect plus lentement le
pouls plus régulier pieplu l'un d'eux
pression sanguine dessin tout ça ça
fonctionne comme ça ça va vers la canton
pas de l'acoss et j'amène un peu verso
soit que en dessous de ces marqueurs là
ça se passe pas bien
peut-être contrôlées possible que ça qui
a éventuellement de 30 ans y avoir
montée on va avoir des rêves et des
bouffées de chaleur nos rêves ou
indifférents ça va tout changer
si on est un partenaire des livres nous
bousculer un peu parce qu'on bouffe
peut-être peu plus son rang france plus
ça dérange les autres manteaux j'étais
au fait que embellie jacques sont déjà
portés à sa tête un peu plus parler dans
leur sommeil ou et est un peu plus
somnambule que ça ça boit bousculent au
soleil que c'est possible ou en
recherche
on demande aux gens de prendre d'alcool
depuis l'heure du midi ok à moins de
faire des recherches et alcoolique ne
pas en prendre le café pareil pas trop
non plus pas ça bouscule les zones de
comportement du sommet du dôme à la
transforme tout sauf éclaboussa
transforme et la bague ou la montre où
l'application ce téléphone voile devrait
probablement moins que ça et c'est
d'estimé des vrais paramètres de sommeil
parfois ça a réussi pour pire
par exemple on a fait une recherche qui
comparaît une veste intelligente
aujourd'hui justaucorps ce que des
centres la respiration sa mesure la
position commune des pêches le dos sur
le côté ou suivante
et puis sa mesure le coeur d'un taxi
cardiaque le rythme cardiaque
après ces trois paramètres là une
étudiante elle a fait un genre
d'algorithmes de mesures d' analyse qui
sur sa demande sa naissance et c'est par
ici quoi le comparer aux a récemment
confié la bourse nous vraie machine qui
vraiment au microscope
c'est son havre est la vraie mesure la
règle d'or
on a comparé les yeux parfois de travail
à la russie a fini la grippe pour faire
une estimation qui est pompier c'est pas
top notch voulu l'enlever de débit
l'endormissement parce que ils
confondaient l'endormissement avec des
zones cérébrales rapide pipeau bouger
avec le sommeil paradoxal parce qu'on
règle qui arrive pourtant sur les 10 90
on ne jouait pas avec ça mais ça donne
une certaine body mais généralement la
plupart des logiciels d'aidé à gorée
puis les équipements vont estimer ici
d'abord si tu donnes tu dors pas ça ça
marche assez bien
c'est en somme il est profond aux pommes
plus ou moins bien si ce rêve ou pas
assez mauvais comme estimations au long
de ces mauvais pour en savoir marcher
très très bien il tombe dans la fenêtre
de paramètres qui ont développé la
compagnie puis je tombe dans le modèle
cave et puis d'exor des gens
neurotypiques comme on dit pointe
maintenant ça reste de pas marcher
beaucoup parce que ta façon de dormir
est pas pareil
un enfant teddy rage de repos comme
comme un adulte sain comme un personnage
est déprimé ou demande ceci dit sérapis
système ne répondent pas encore biais à
ces variations là j'ai tout allait comme
on pense tout là c'est tout un même la
recherche a toujours été comme ça des
jeunes étudiants blancs la plupart des
données qu'on avait jusqu'à ya pas si
longtemps une vingtaine d'années s'était
basé sur des mesures prises ces des
étudiants au baccalauréat aux états unis
dont l'un d'eux les coûts proteste un
tank à des horaires ranger qui saute
alors je pense pas tout on sera content
les personnes de race noire donc pas
pareil
on parlait même de contrôler la pression
sanguine que d'autres d'autres ethnies
jeter on recommence à s'intéresser à ce
puits environnement joue énormément là
dessus tu peux tu peux jumeler un type
d'environnement avec une race ou une
ethnie souvent qu'autrement sa clique
des choses aussi d'accord on est plus
d'appuis commenceront à recherche
beaucoup plus social à ce que
l'environnement où est-ce que tu restes
le quartier de la bourgogne et des autos
l'étude du monde dans ta famille était
votre souverain que ça vienne condé rit
parce qu'il se mettre comme un genre de
baromètre se disent avoir subi sur vos
premiers dommages pas ça va mal il ya
quelque chose qui voit mal physique
mental environnementale des clauses qui
vont pas même temps que la bagdat bagne
où le bracelet ou la vs pitso attrapa
tout sera en ligne de compte on en
change d'environnement mais toi tu ci
est capable de calculer ma variation par
rapport à moi mais oui dans le même et
au même endroit une salle de classe le
tout à fait chaque fois que ça m'est
arrivé de dormir ailleurs depuis que
j'ai 7 bat glace et tout le temps un
sommet vraiment vraiment moins bon selon
les paramètres qui ont circulé dans ma
base à 6 ans et ben ouais ça c'est fort
mais on en reparlera après le podcast
donc en mettant à l'essai deux parties
vraiment dans notre quête de
compréhension de ce mail roma de la base
de pourquoi condamner parce que mettons
deux on dirai qui tu es d'un point de
vue et d'évolution il ya un petit
quelque chose qui fait pas de sens at
dans le sens de être complètement
arrêtée pendant huit heures par est en
train de chasser et cueillir à être un
peu à une 3 facilité parce qu'on est
petit mais pourtant c'est essentiel c
est qu est ce qui fait qu on est obligé
de s'arrêter complètement pendant huit
heures par jour
bastien car john normand montcourt
d'abord ce serait sans doute un
je dis tout le temps tu es s'il fallait
ramper nos besoins primaires se nourrir
se reprocher c'est à dire un petit
territoire
deux heures par jour ça ça correct et
reproduit tous mangé un peu tabou dans
ta caverne c'est fini que deux là se
serait terminée puisqu'on serait 22h
protéger quand les mammouths
c'est pour être protégé comme cela mais
ces poissons des cadeaux qui nous oblige
à être réveillés parce que des fonctions
puisque ont évolué comme espèce plus des
fonctions compliqua j'ai des fonctions
qu'on fait con con qu'on va accomplir
pendant un conte d'hans présentons la
mise en mémoire mais le sommeil
paradoxal qui se met où on raye du
sommet où est-ce qu'on ma mémoire ce
qu'on a appris on a peut-être un peu
plus parlons-en
il ya deux sortes de sommeil embrouille
sommet ils la conduisent à un stade
moins de trois occasions vue ou un du
troll selon sa profondeur la profondeur
ça veut dire que quels genres de
stimulation ou ça prend pour te
réveiller de sortir de l'eau et puis
c'est tout ce qu'on connaissait jusque
dans les années 1955 à peu près à ce
moment là on ne les croit sur des paires
de claques et un sommeil qui tout aussi
profond ça prend autant de bruit tout
réveiller ou à peu près puis même plus
compliqué parce que ce soit les bruits
qui signifiant 6 nice l'absence
éducation ça travaille repassé juste ton
prénom si on va te réveiller cependant
d'un os à risque à moins d'être venu en
soi mais lancer vraiment la quantité de
nourriture pour retrouver la personne
qui forment un sommeil paradoxal que
c'est très très différents par françois
meylan tout est ralenti il pour moody's
est tous terrés nantis comme ça à la
personne par aversa les ondes cérébrales
sont rapides
on est paralysée vraiment sous certains
muscles on respire quand même les yeux
beau pour toutes les directions
gauche-droite 3 rebonds convergence
divergence et tout ce que la personne
anglais appellent à un mouvement de
sommeil le sommeil paradoxal on est donc
réactivé la pression sanguine augmente
la respiration haletante
c'est comme ça on en réchappe chiffre
d'affaires que c'est très très très dur
est-ce qu'on réagit aux stimuli de nos
rêves ou nécessairement lire ici niveau
plus compliqué un peu chier gerrie britz
cet attrait
parce qu'on parlait du besoin de dormir
donc paradoxale si le combat mais moi ce
qu'on a appris pendant 1 journée pendant
journée est ce qu'on a appris
si c'est important ils vont rester dans
des structures du cerveau dans les
hippocampes qu'on apaise patron ne
serrez pas les mots restent hélas avoir
barboté ça va me jeter ça vaut rester de
kraton dans il ya un dialogue qui se
fait entre les profondeurs du cerveau
plaques aux alentours du cerveau qu'on
appelle le cortex ça se parle et des
déciles de nerveuse qui font des fibres
entre les deux pugilistes informations
obtenant vos pieds en roulotte
l'information qu'on a un souvenir précis
ces conditions des pulsions nerveuse
c'est sur notre mémoire mais sous forme
d'une protéine cette protéine ans va
rester là d'un cortex puis la cave à
rester si mémoire à long terme parlant
sommeil confession en ligne les espèces
les espèces de base des fourmis les vers
de terre pour grand chose à apprendre
cette journée sont très bien adaptés à
leur milieu sûr mais puisqu'on a évolué
puisque nos cerveaux grossi puisque
l'accès frontale aux gros aussi dans la
même boîte que s'est aussi replié
ça fait sorte de plus qu'on ne divague
des circonvolutions parce que le cube
beaucoup plus d'espacé si on ouvrait la
tête
on sortait cerveau condé où on est allé
si gros gros le plus c'est autres à tête
et tout répit pour occuper plus de
surface comme un prune ou un peu aux
noix de grenoble dans son coin
c'est vraiment vraiment comme ça qu'ils
aiment ou du side by side si oui où une
séquence volution si comme un cerveau de
grosses fesses des bébés plus que toi un
animal qui confiait puisqu'elle se
convolution et beaucoup de travail à
faire parce qu'on fait de la
socialisation la quête de nourriture est
différente
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de matériel qui
ce fait puis on peut plus traiter tout
le matériel online en direct de temps
faut en garder pitre et et offline
pendant une semaine entre autres parce
que jamais ils ont la réponse souvent
qu'on vous dit je vais te laisser parler
après la raccordant donc ça sera en
mémoire qu'il répond souvent qu'on va
donner que ce déclin mais qu'il pensait
à sa fait
sentent en confiance semaine passée par
comme quoi on dort aussi c'est plusieurs
choses différentes
puis rossi ont fait jamais dans mon
section d'appel chanel mal de dos mais
vont mourir sauf qu'il va mourir pas
d'infection pas de rééditer va mourir
parce qu'il déballe ans et qui mange
plus c'est températures basses ça marche
plus la bataille de ses cpu c'est pire
qu'un disciple warin harmonie ensemble
puis finit par en mourir de dépit comme
si une machine se déboîte comme si la
chaîne au chef de letat moto ou un débat
qui est le miroir marche pipe il les
livre est à la marche pas non plus mais
ce n'est pas ce qui se passe à 16 10
truites cesse comme ça signifiait et
plus ça fonctionne plus dessous du tout
l'accueil c'est à ces impératifs aussi
on note dans le cerveau une partie qui
dit jeudi soir et veiller toute partie
qui disjoncte dans les parties là sont
en attaque en isme les un compte d un
contredit leurs composantes les uns
contre les autres
pendant une heure lors sans talent dans
cette vraie neige vers l'or dont les
cellules vont vont vont s'agiter plus
puni les plus leurs activités une fois
par 24 à un peu à peu près c'est un peu
plus que 24h 24 pour les quelque chose
quand mais chaque matin à trouver la
lumière
sarah juste la montre c'est l'armé à la
maison on recommence un peu la journée
que ça avant que ça avance
ce qui fait que on n'est plus capable de
prolonger une journée de l'abc peu parce
que j'ai 6 ans de son choix cumul du
sommeil a moins mal dormi et ça
fonctionne général peut très très très
vives ou peu rallongé pour travailler à
votre iphone
peu importe on peut aller jusqu'à un
certain point même si à des effets
défaut délétère son compte une voiture
perd donc saddier et père actif de
dormir il s'était dit de la faute
d'hommes passion on a durant à refaire
doute l'on utilise amène le même cerveau
la même boîte à films ça aide à prendre
ça comme des ordis vont servir afin de
la bureautique le jeu au pied à émettre
des chèques de paye la nuit on n'a plus
trop je préviens je ne vais pas parfaite
c'est ça que ça fait donc c'était
impératif de dormir puis on peut pas
comme c'est tantôt de paupières ça si
c'est tellement puissant cances ferme
puis le coup abaissé pour perdre le fil
des fois on va parler avec une personne
qui tout lien avec nous puis le discours
commence est un petit peu erratique
c'est à compter l'autre et sa puissance
c'est peut être plaisant de voir parents
sont partenaires de dee qui commence à
s'endormir pour voir les yeux qui
roulent lentement lentement sous 18
lisieux ont bougé d'un management
pascontent à le contrôler la position du
zune est désormais de pyros tribu c'est
un peu ce qui fait que quand on on
écoute quelqu'un qui est ennuyé dans une
entrevue par exemple il voisin pas
pousser du coude paixhans dans on va
voir le blanc des yeux en premier parce
qu'on perd le contrôle de son espèce non
l'orientation dans l'espace qu'on
accepte ou non et non pour 1 % seraient
les terrassements malo puis on s'entende
avance distincts coup d'y penser ça peu
d'histoire et c'est le fruit tout petits
sites où courent pas grand chose parce
que la mesure concerne doigt comme ça on
pas le contrôle nous penser aussi que
cette vague faut sortir de cette image
dimanche soir il récurrente un peuple
s'il veut plus compulsifs tout seul mais
c'est nous oublie france avoir passé le
sas donc on est réveillé on passe par le
chas qui se mélangent y voit deux
supports devrais-je votre propre
l'oeuvre est comme un tapis dans l'eau
froide et chaude où je vois toujours du
pot puis ce sera impératif d'y aller si
je suis bien stress et sur les bénéfices
que je pourrai glee je veux pas y aller
je rate on a des réponses aujourd'hui
demain jeunes entrevue classics baptisé
de quoi je vois par des questions poser
comme question puis si tout le monde
compte du groupe o je m'en sers comment
je vais me rendre à destination ou à ces
domaines j'achète mon auto c'est demain
que que je raconte telle personne j'ai
une entrevue saviez trop urgents pâtasse
le sommeil quand vous savez ces
résultats nous tous sur le trou chose à
faire même c'est moins important que ce
soit jean cauchy plus tard je me range
et moi mais [ __ ] mais soit on fait son
propre parti fin que ça commence
si la commande c'est de dire éveil
tantôt c'est sony qui va prendre en cas
de chauffage va s'en occuper fac et deux
régions du cerveau sont en équilibre
comme ça puis l'horloge la 10éme à
m'endormir cette horloge l'eau à
plusieurs autres horloges esclaves
guillemets qui vont faire baisser la
température baisse et la tempête
après son sanguine faire sécréter
certaines hormones en namibie d'autres
aussi changer de tresser petit vite et à
l'environnement
toutes les sensations qu'on reçoit
vision d'audition de chuck température
ça passe par nos récepteurs nos doigts
notre langue et nos oreilles ça en vaut
canaliser vers le même endroit du
cerveau s'appelle le thalamus thalamus
lui sa job se disent assez de louis jean
va sortir régions du cerveau associée
des visions j'ai fait tout ça mais quand
on commence à s'endormir
l'horloge faire en sorte que ça envoie
désormais des neurotransmetteurs qui
vont inhiber le thalamus puis thalamus
pas pu renvoyer des choses tellement 22
01 - dissimulation tacle ça laisse la
place aux systèmes de sommeil à rentrer
ce bout des pieds qui rentrent et puis
prendre la place je trouverai je me
lance en sommeil et les pilules pour
dormir c'est ce que ça fait ça ne
s'endort pas nécessairement directement
sa baisse le d'éveil sans peine les
formations d'aller au complet vers de
grandes enveloppes ce cortex fille qui
quitte cette information bien on peut
dors mais ces bons moments passés mais
en plus on apprend le matin d'une plaie
du primaire se nomment julie sénécal
main peut même un fardeau que c'est pas
le moment de dormir le matin
bon là je veux pas qu'on dorme nous on
doit quentinois habituellement quand on
est jeune mais bien et bien organisée
donc c'est assez épais ratissent partout
dans une région du cerveau en charge de
son puits un système qui supervise qui
tue qui maman dormait au moment dé
travailler normalement
à moins que des contradictions on est
malade on dit stressée mal des douleurs
physiques qui de la psychologique tout
cela offre des modules de soap ci est
relativement fragile c'est pour les
somistes un vrai baromètre ça nous dit
est ce que ça va bien ou pas bien quatre
ans dort pas bien et hongroise il ya
quelque chose qui me chicote qui vaut
probable soit que j'ai mal aux pieds
soit que je préoccupé par quelque chose
je crois que j'ai pris un nouveau
médicament serait pas mon affaire
j'ai changé ma diète j'étais libre et le
testament ça dépend beaucoup de son
avant de parler tu étais l'on peut
sonner dans l'insomnie
qu'est-ce-qui qu'aux piquès comment
qu'on peut on peut le gérer mais je
voulais revenir en arrière au site il
leur faut l'on comprend que le sommeil
si vraiment vital le thé est carrément
cespi lippi puis ne tire vos process
informations on magasine les acquis les
mods on voit tes certaines personnes
vont voir le sommeil comme quelque chose
qu'on peut
coupe et qu'on peut raccourcir pour qu
en dites à être productif 6e j'imagine
que vous allez vous amuser qu est un
mauvais réflexe de vouloir faire ce dock
et j'ai effectivement c'est un réflexe
est vraiment les mauvais parce qu'on
essaie de faire mieux ou de faire plus
si on est plusieurs à avoir ce rêve là
c'était motivation alors il ya un choix
juste mais pourquoi pourquoi vous voulez
faire sauf qu'au bout de temps mais
seulement quatre heures par nice mais
passe a dormi voulait bien on rêve
d'être au repos personnes nous acharnons
il un cocon ses supérieurs parfois de
quelqu'un coutinho que c'est le fun
pourquoi c'est empêcher de faire ça
c'est le sentiment de perdre du temps
d'en faire plus
c'est une autre question qui prendra qui
se porte à même chose dans les relations
sociales la façon de manger c'est pas
juste ça mais moi je pense que le style
de vie se doivent leur a causé son
cheval puis ça marche pas mais j'imagine
qu'ils aient on peut mesurer cas précis
une fois réveillé en ayant dormi la
moitié de ce tas voulait être plus
productif on laisse au mans - oui on
peut dire que dans l'intéressant c'est
qu'on peut constater que dormait -4
aperçoit déjà faire soi même ceux qui
disent qu'ils font c'est pas vraiment la
perception du sommeil on s'en rend pas
compte non plus on commence à
s'interroger sur la valeur des micro
sommeil de dormir trois secondes
c'est vrai que ça fait quelque chose de
pas de jours les appels entrant à contre
temps de mettre les machines en place
puisque c'est peut-être pas même ça se
passe on sait maintenant que quand on
dort et de cette partie du cerveau qui
se réveille
puis comme dit que c'est l'excellent
unix et amis qui se réveillent au son
qui font un petit job si la position
européenne où seul un pic sincère
clignote comme ça partout on commence
avec là dedans
on savait de toute façon macroscopique
que des animaux qui dorment pas
ministère à la fois admis sa voix la
fois les canaux canard on décale vers
les dauphins certains otaries dogues
restent à l'affût des dangers respirer
sous l'eau il respire pas nous prennent
une respiration il ya des zones et
tourner dans l'autre sens parce que
votre cerveau qui fonctionne qui centre
on peut même y voir même des fois
l'école vers le fond les canards de fond
un seul est ouvert effectivement ils
peuvent guetter cd présentant pas loin
puis d'homme de le côté ça fonctionne
dans le temps de la guerre froide les
années 1960 on disait que les russes
entraîner des dauphins dans dans l'océan
pourra surveiller céder sous mer et demi
qui s'enlève que ça dort jamais ça il ya
toujours une émission de voir et qu'ils
entraînaient pika que le dauphin
percevait soumaré tel qu on lui avait
enseigné de détecter mais faisaient pas
de poètes puis avertissait que le
numérique janvier par exemple donc ça
existe ça c'est encore plus réfléchi
plus microscopique que soit possiblement
pas que notre cerveau est pas dans un
des taux unique complète une stabilité
dans le temps d'y penser car auch de
chaos organisé ça s'allume c'est un peu
ça fonctionne très mal mais c'est
vraiment une technologie extraordinaire
un cerveau qui dort un peu comme du coup
ce qui fait que de vouloir dormir -
c'est pas ça mais payant parce qu'on
peut voir que pendant un jour c'est
jonathan mais peu ont dit soit un musée
d'essen d'inventeurs des lampes au long
d'une sorte de défense et de sa fausse
on dort moins passant de l'énergie qui
lui dormait très très très peu ils y ont
découvert j'ai des photos j'ai trouvé le
des photos des sceaux fois partout dans
six bureaux faisait des petits des
familles et c'est à sa chérie de
l'organdi dormait peu partout ce n'est
pas à des gens qui disent qu'ils dorment
beaucoup qui donc très très peu moins de
quatre heures je ne crois pas en partant
ces 5 10e me trouve et on va le tester
voir si on mettait c'est surtout pas la
journée commence fonctionne un piège m
aucun moment même aux toilettes
tous vos toilettes et heures 26 minutes
de la pause de fermer excuse moi c'est
quoi optimalement a fait le nombre
d'actes qui est que en moyenne on
dormait on dort le nombre d'heures qui
nous conviennent cour fonctionne bien
pendant la journée
c'est comme c'est comme la taille dépit
des gorges chaudes 34 des coachs aux
quarante deux des filles c'est pareil
tout le monde sinon jarry la donne et il
ya des gens qui sont plus fragiles ou
froid puis d'autres moins fragiles ou
froid plus assez de l'alcool moins
sensibles à l'alcool
le sommeil c'est ce dont on a besoin que
la façon de mieux
justement c'est à dire moi je me rends
compte qu'en jetant vacances ou les fins
de semaine je dorme de 2 11 heures le
soir s'attendre le matin ça fait 8
heures village de fenêtres le 6 il
convient donc ça doit être moi c'est de
9 heures le soir à 6 ans le matin à 5h
le matin à moins de 2 heures du matin à
10h 11h du matin puis fx mais cette
fenêtre la bauge ladurie bouge aussi
quand on est petit bébé pour une longue
fenêtres on doit pendant longtemps est à
peu près n'importe quand on savait peu
après 4h à nourrir quand on vieillit
vacances et se met dix milieux diminue
dix minutes 10 minutes
quand on arrive à l'adolescence il reste
à peu près autour de 9h 9h30 semble-t-il
miss la fnai tu as beau jeu on se couche
plus tard pour c'est plus long on peut
même définir le début de puberté
au moment de leur manque de sommeil sont
au pic de ses créations commencent à se
décaler vers l'hôpital c'est également
ça bouge en ce que je sais c'est pas
juste un c'est pas juste par lâcheté
d'un adolescent à temps partiel même moi
mais quand j'étais ado les sages des
fois je me levais à 11 heures les
week-ends choses qui sont impossibles
maintenant dans ma ville c'est ça pour
sûr des raisons les synchronisant donc
on est hors de leurs deux pièces et
candeur sociaux aussi aller à l'école
quand tu es dans la sefa des langes
toujours quelque chose qui ne qui nous
occupe qui nous guide dans notre rêve
donc tu arrives à l'adolescence tu as
fait ta bouche se coucha plus tard se
lève plus tard puisque tout passe et
dormi tu dormiras 20 plus tard des fins
de semaine super de la traite tout
bouger un peu plus tard travailler
beaucoup plus tard et le du matin temps
viennent d'europe
le site offrira des calabrais de l'océan
dans des caves 3 4h des poids total ce
que période où les lieux-dits matinée
que seconde à jour offre un acte utile
c'est quand même 30 et votre exigeante
péripate la matière si les mathématiques
à vos côtés jusqu'à 10 ce matin sous nos
doigts avec correction atteint 6,6 et
d'autres domaines très différents
et puis à mesure qu'on vieillit ensuite
parce que des siestes par exemple des
enfants je reviens quatre cinq six ans
quand on rate aux primaires là il y en
aurait fait une sieste des saisies
paraissent effectivement pis y'a plus
qu'à peu près 20% des enfants pour des
siestes en corse avant de rentrer quatre
attaquants c'est terminé
effectivement dskgate % des gens qui
sont des siestes heures naturel encore
rendu à 30 ans 40 ans il ferait encore
17 points forts encore s'ils ont le
loisir de le faire s'il travaille comme
comme qui ont eu lieu par exemple ils
m'ont prouvé leur petite sieste
donc cette fenêtre là à voir se
transformer de plusieurs parties de
sommeil par nuit jusqu'à une seule
partie de ce feuilleton n'est même pas
sorti c'est la bonne affaire à faire bon
viendra pas de dormir quatre appuis et
dormir plusieurs petits bouts points
enfin des cistes sporadiques c'est ça ou
du sommeil au diphasique comme les gens
qui ont la transat qui donne un coup de
se réveiller donc on arrive alors j'ai
adultes pour cela travailler à 18 ans du
vin et en 25 heures on se mettrait à
yvonand de plus je crois faut rentrer au
travail rentrer et à l'appui partir à
tallard selon la plupart des gens qui
travaillent mais sa vie et qui depuis
notre sommeil pis la tête est déjà prête
l'horloge est déjà prête pour accueillir
ce genre d'affaires mais les gens qui
sont des types de soi qui naturellement
s'il mesure de ressemer y avait qu une
bague ou demandons c'est vraiment mon
meilleur c'est quand je me couche à deux
ans je me lève à 10 il fait beau la
terre ils réussissent pas obsédé qu'il
soit effectivement ça fonctionne pas
très bien donc il faut que je fasse
violence est plus ce qu al oui évoluent
ils vont évoluer et spontanément vers un
titre de travail qui permet plus tôt
mais ça aussi c'est ce que cds que c'est
réel les distinctions entre ce qu'on dit
mais chez moi je suis plus productif le
matin ou avec quelqu'un qui dimanche
plus productif le soir c'est quelque
chose qui est qui et qui réel c'est
juste une construction sociale qu'on se
fait selon l'horaire conséquences qu'on
régule régularise c'est réel mais c'est
influencé par les situations sociales
par exemple quand on passe d'un
questionnaire de chronos cip chronos
type c15 genre de type qui tu es en
fonction du temps c'est du matin soit
intermédiaire carrey prend déjà son type
intermédiaire quel pourcentage de chaque
côté qui sont vraiment des trois audi
team du matin mais en plus et déjà que
voudra bien un type de soin mais on
pourrait envoyer de le faire parce qu'on
dise enfin vous savez ma l'autobus les
longues pizza vitalis enquête contre
qu'approuver cette question là bas c'est
que social et des influences béroul
biologique notre biologie qui très très
très s'adaptent très plastique on peut
jouer avec ce qu il est un peu tombée
plus tard
on peut réussir à le faire comme il est
difficile très trop que j'ai dit car
c'est au grand vent de le roseau qui est
qui dans cette langue qui ploie minéraux
paul est un peu on est inquiet comme ça
fait compatibles soir et s'adapte un
petit peu
elle connaît des gens qui sont des vrais
type de soin qui s'endorment 1 2h du
matin vers 8 heures du matin
la durée de sommeil sablais papier ils
sont et ont toujours dit on toujours du
même nom déjà travaillé pareil en
seulement 7 eur puis à fonctionner une
naturelle c'est parce qu'ils pourraient
savoir ce soit qu'on a un gadget une
montre la gauche comme ça où on remplit
chaque matin pour une fois par trois
matin mais chaque matin décrit là qu'on
s'est couché là qu'on s'est levé puis
comment de conserver pendant la nuit
professeurs tout temps pendant au moins
trois semaines
parce que cette semaine on change
d'horaires sur des enfants ça change des
choses surtout en ncaa de partager ce
soit préparé non plus si on voit notre
sur notre blonde qui est fin de semaine
seulement si on a un deuxième travail
que par eux mêmes ou encore est toujours
devant une classe conception faisons pas
trop has marois avait - s'est couché
vers tala mail vie verte à l'arc c'est
de prendre le temps tab 6 à la cassine
sommet qu'on a besoin puis on peut faire
ça à 10h fonctionne bien aller vers son
rapport petit d'insomnie nal inverse
quand on dit que kate et son ex chéri
qui dit je fonctionne mal le jour près
mes critères parce que je dors bien la
nuit parce qu'on pu dormir peut déjà qui
tombe cinq heures puis fonctionne très
très bien et elle exprime le sommet qui
donne 5 ans fonctionne pas très très
bien
factieux qui dit qui donne quatre heures
dragué mesurer moins leur temps de
réaction prise de décision et pull cif
irritable sk pas des petites mesures
comme ça qui les différencie des autres
je vais donc on a une biologie qui nous
oblige à dormait après son os adapté
comme on nomme des hublots différentes
qui gambadent ce faire on s'adapte un
peu avec nos propres caractéristiques
personnelles pour ça devient
l'environnement dans lequel on évolue
il ya des gens que ça doit te bien au
changement d'heure déjà que ça te plait
pas très aimé changement dans et des
gens qui s'adapte bien vivre dans les
régions circumpolaires des gens qui
réussissent pas s'y adapter à ça il ya
des facteurs génétiques qui protège des
souliers des facteur environnemental le
support que l'auto on peut pas dissocier
tout ce qui est social environnemental
de ski biologique l'un faye vol d'ubs et
de l'autre est ce que je me trompe si je
dis
parce que j'ai entendu ce que pour avoir
pour maximiser son voeu cet horaire là
c'est mieux d'avoir un heures de levée
constante qu'une heure de coucher
constants moi j'ai toujours dit ça parce
que l'heure du lever on a contrôlé ses
malheurs du coucher arrive plein et
pondérée en plein d'événements subi
inattendus qui vont changer notre heure
du coucher pour des raisons puis lors du
levé on peut la régler facilement on
peut pas la prolonger leur dû lever
outre monsieur passe quand on quand on
aura rempli la chaudière de sommeil on
va serait des lipides piquant aussi
maintenant moi je suis en ce moment mais
j'ai toujours dormi beaucoup les fans
semaine j'ai toujours été vraiment les
photos le tir je me levais souvent les
fins de semaine les photos le pardon
pardon ça n'enlève par les stars les
fins de semaine sauf que là depuis
depuis leur confinement j'imagine je
mets mon cadran à 8h30 à tous les matins
depuis la fin de semaine même quand
j'essaie de me laisser aller plus
longtemps 8h30 clean les deux yeux bien
ouverts peu importe alors que je me suis
couché la veille à 8h30 à tous les
matins et mannequins img pas de cadre en
avait peut-être que vous vieillissez
cher ami ben on dirait 710 ses six
passes
parce qu'en vieillissant c'est selon on
a moins besoin de deux longtemps
différemment compare les défaites de
portus mais je sais ça fait plaisir je
me choque parce que ma famille en otage
et goûter
mais c'est une réaction normale on en
profite on en profite
si ces demandes parce que c'est une
bonne raison de la détérioration c'est
un changement le réseau des rhumatismes
tranquillement ville donc ça évolue
cette fenêtre d'opportunité l'eau quand
on vieillit on voit se coucher peut-être
un petit peu la même heure peut-être un
peu plus tôt on voit surtout servir
plutôt puy-en-velay dur de jouer avec ce
plutôt long qui a duré le sommet elle
voir accès donc on va les renier un peu
l'heure du lever de mettre un pied lors
du coucher demain le soir sans avoir
fait une perte de sommeil plus courte
puis 4-1 d'imputer synchroniseur sociaux
plusieurs mois se mettent à refaire des
six est cependant journée comme des gens
font maintenant pendant la pandémie
picon et confinées à la maison
plusieurs ont fait des siestes ont lancé
les gens le font plus
par contre pendant le confinement les
gens perdent les rapports habituels qui
est synchroniseur environnementaux celui
de travail et s'habiller se tenir
déjà on auprès peu de doute là-dessus
pire ils vont voir et ce mec hyper sud à
cause de son qui appelaient toutes
choses qui se passent plus de cauchemars
et est donc un projet isambara mathurin
parce qu'on vieillit à passer un
incendie au monde dont je m'habille nous
en août étape concernant plus quand on
est plus conscient soit surtout sont en
train dé mesure de son propre réseau
dans ce procès comme avant on dort pas
dans mes façons on perd du sommeil envie
ça c'est certain on perd surtout le
sommet le plus profond le sommeil lent
profond 10 ans sont les plus profondes
dit c'est parce que c'est des ondes
qu'on ne voit plus mais on savait pas et
des fonctions cérébrales sont moins
bonnes sont différentes puis le
thermomètre comprend et puis fiable et
beaupuy saison dans l'automatisme n ya
plus un ou deux noms au sommet on
l'emmenait sur mes protect profond
encore par contre on le terme à l'aide
comprend et ma pression sanguine
disparaît les autres éléments sont là
paraît donc à mesure qu'on évolue dans
la vie ne sommet arrête pas de changer
tout le temps tout le temps tout inconnu
vous entendez justement un spécialiste
vous connaissez matthew webb
pis il y parlait de ce justement tandis
que justement à calage avançons dans -10
puis parler du déclin cognitif à la
vieillesse dit qu'on est toujours
associé ce au processus normal de
vieillissement mais qu'en réalité you
say we aussi un lien avec le fait
peut-être qu'on doit - là par lte et la
démence qui apparaît et pitt et toutes
ces choses le pire que peut-être que si
on réussissait à garder un sommet
meilleur plus long plus longtemps à sa
vie on pourrait retarder tout s'est fait
le projet d'accord il ya toute une
histoire autour de son dirigeant disait
encore cette semaine parce que journée
laisse moi écrit pour dire qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ce qui faisait que grande
étude épidémiologique sur dix mille
personnes montre que moins on dort
puisqu'on se développer une démence
c'est il ya un biais en partant parce
que play de littérature qui manque plus
qu on dort longtemps puisqu'on refuse de
mourir jeunes dont l'histoire ont les
moyens 10 des études de des méta analyse
de 25 études qui montrent la même
affaire maladies cardiovasculaires mais
on voit toujours relevé le côté 18 pas
assez dormi observant une morale faut
vous dormiez buteur frau que pippo times
est un chercheur en somme est un
clinicien sommeil mais l'offre condé
exagère faut pas refaire une morale une
obligation c'est contre nature
on danse qu'on a besoin de dormir puis
si on dort moins en vieillissant c'est
comme ça qu'il faut le d'étudier le
comprends mais c'est pas vrai que s'est
associé pour moi là je constate c'est
pas vrai que ça serve à plus de démence
gens dépensent plus rapidement ya
tellement de facteurs génétiques famille
d'où viennent ces données l'eau et des
données présentes qui montrait que moi
on ne remontera plus omar jeunes étaient
présents des familles génétiquement
didier de cinq six mille personnes qui
avaient tous à peu près d'elle grimm qui
partagent un patrimoine génétique qui
font en sorte qu'il doit au moins une
fois ceux qui ont plus de quinze fois
plus nombreuses qu'en fait aussi taxés
deux facteurs qui évolue en même temps
c'est pas eux qui causent autres une
corrélation dans une corrélation les
gens les plus intelligents ont les yeux
plus va pas déçu qu'on n'ait pas
personne a des yeux plus noires
paraissait corrélation s'est pas les une
oie qui font en sorte que type gt
legends
ces deux affaires et voilà maintenant il
est trop comme un haka qu'il faut qu'on
essaie de comprendre le fait de dire
mais la tuberculose il ya plein de gens
qui disaient encore la semaine passée
c'était encore quand le rendant plus le
canton doit passer on veut devenir des
mains plus rapidement l'inversé est
aussi vrai et puis sans rentrer dans le
complotisme c'est certain que ceux qui
fabriquent des produits pour dormir pas
juste les pilules mais tous les produits
qui disent que les machines qui font des
pépites sont des gens là veulent bien
sûr nous dire vous dormez pas c'est vous
et dormir mieux avec ce que j'ai ici il
ya personne qui va dire on va réduire le
sommeil des gens qui domine trop tard
qu'ils adorent mais ce n'est pas une
industrie process de peau avec un on
n'oublie pas qu'il ya un biais de
sélection d'informations dedans aussi
puis je suis convaincu que on regarde
seulement d'un côté et un épisode de law
côté convaincu desssus juste par
curiosité ce monsieur est ce que c'est
quelqu'un qui qui qui qui respecte et
piqué ou si quelqu un qui fait cavalier
seul impôt non non non ce poste par
infra tireurs locaux
il est connu il fait des conférences il
vulgarise beaucoup il ya la boue qui
fonctionne bien fondé bonne recherche du
son mais c'est après qu'est ce qu'on a
fait ou qu'est ce qu'on veut pour moi
c'est ça n'excuse intéressant de dire on
est une société malade qui doit passer
de soi mais une mesure entre eux pas
dormir assez une arme qui n'a par
exemple péter saugnac souffre la
détresse n'est pas bien
c'est un hymne est on fonctionne en
continu d'argent comme ce qui est pas
dormir assez brin de se priver nous tous
les cas nasion dans 52 mais qu'est ce
qu'on devrait dormir son comparé aux
vacances pidoux fin de semaine par
rapport aux dunes travailleront donc pas
si c'est vrai mais des crises cardiaques
non non il n'y a pas un lien qui
tiraient en tous sens maintenant qu'il
compare une heure de sommeil je pense
25% d'augmentation cristian zaccardo
pourquoi pensez même pas faire un lien
clair protocole pour le comprendre ce
public et laboratoires de recherche à
l'image aussi puissent aller avec mon
collègue qui fait de la sorcellerie des
la biochimie
faudrait développer protocole pour sa
part aussi de comprendre oui de
comprendre pourquoi bien plus d'actions
contre un peu mieux ça les crises
cardiaques des avc experts vasculaires
cérébraux pourquoi on est au comprend
podium l'explication donnent souvent
c'est que ça favorise l'expression de on
est un peu des cytokines des hormones
sur le feu la lutte contre les
infections qui sont des balances et l'a
toujours dit pro inflammatoire qui
favorisent l'inflammation pas t'en veux
pour te battre
puis les ans ces femmes à toi toujours
une balle en ce sens qu'on prends des
anti inflammatoires par la bouche le par
médicaments prime mais ça nous aide à
combattre au grand d'inflammation ça
prenne ce n'est pas trop la balance
puis le changement d'heure ferait
peut-être méchant demande à 6 15 août
affirme on prend par des tentes ou pas
j'ai un éditorial d'affaires de 680
mais cette partie là donc il faut garder
le côté de trop dormi c'est pas bien
aussi c'est une balance dans nos chacun
notre balance quand on vieillit le
sommaire apsys a toujours été depuis
qu'on le mesure entre convenablement
puis ça fait la sphère de bain du monde
qui se réparti autrement de faire des
siestes le jour c'est peut-être pas
mauvais pour des personnes qui sont
attendues au bornage peut le faire comme
ça l'est pour des petits
on sait aussi m'intéresser à des petits
tout petit il perd payant et en fondant
magasinage de matériel appris pendant
journée par an 1,6 mais c'est peut-être
vrai pour d'autres personnes qui en font
un peu plus et les gens qui font les
transats qui va dormir à nîmes 20
minutes au coût de 4 ans une façon de
leur faire défaut
il ya plusieurs publications mata qui
nous rappelle ou qui ont trouvé des
indices qui nous disent que au moyen âge
les gens te faisais deux partis de loin
ils doivent au début j'ai du seuil au
château 1
il serait pendant la nuit pour soi de
raison que possible on n'est pas certain
pour être cessez le feu mais que vous
appuyez dessus manger mais manger pour
le bétail est correct est ce que
quelqu'un est entré dans ma propriété ou
dans notre cabane tout ça puis on
suggère % d'hommes et déjà parfois de
manger les bulles de nuit déjà faisait à
manger du coup ma belle-mère duel son
nom mais ce dont mes plus beaux coups il
a supplié pas vraiment de partout se
fait à nicolas de la société
en tout cas jacques à jade est chez elle
dimanche avait imposé face à ces
mutations rythme elle fonctionnait très
bien comme ça donc il ya un jeu dans son
sac
le social puis l'environnement nous
oblige à fond qu'une certaine façon puis
la biologie qui voudraient confort d'une
autre façon s'accommode biais l'un
l'autre chose c'est que vous n'êtes pas
alarmiste a à dire qu'il ya une épidémie
de manque de sommeil dans la société
moderne il ya on sera beaucoup plus que
des gens aient saugnac qui fonctionne
mal le jour parce qu'ils dorment la nuit
qu'on dort pas beaucoup
oui on a un piètre lettres substance
j'ai un problème que je vois tous les
jours avec les ninjas la clique des
adolescents même des jeunes adultes qui
empiète sur le sommet peut faire plus de
choses c'est un problème je peux
convaincu que ça va les amener à faire
des crises cardiaques plus tard on fait
un lien entre le manque de sommeil puis
développer du diabète et l'obésité qu'il
fait bien souvent quand on dort pas
assez on est plus forte en grèce en rien
ce but on n'est plus tout à fait du
diabète mais quand même quel sommeil
peut avoir des effets pu mener à
l'obésité par exemple aux chroniques
longtemps qu'ils qualifient ce important
de manque de sommeil
savané des problèmes de scientifiques
c'est clair et bien de d'humeur aussi
vite et irritable bassin d'électeurs ça
existait lors il faut pas crier au loup
pourriez part que sa voix perd de son
importance
juste des zèbres c'est comme on nous dit
ben moi j'ai votre groupe fruits moi
j'ai fait deux groupes traités en titre
se passera d ébène dormait lisa dont
vous avez besoin qui me servait plus
frais de bagages de cabine pour des
mesures et donc le temps de chômer que
vous dormez me poser vos questions après
ses succès passés
je sors au plus près des larmes et posés
par les crises cardiaques pour ça est-ce
que
est ce que dans cette optique là on
remarque actuellement une hausse des
problèmes de sommeil liés au stress
c'est parce que le stress est un des
facteurs qui peuvent nuire au sommeil le
plus à moins que je me trompe c'est
quand on n'a pas de contrôle sur sa vie
on devient stressé puis quand on va voir
exercice contre au long de l'exercice ce
soit mais aussi de la marche pour dit il
faut que je dorme maintenant la course
est serrée depuis que proposes endormez
pas ce coffee shops tunique soi-même
prouve aux normes et sa fonction et ses
soeurs exacte tout le monde on a tous
vécu deux dans notre lit puis de penser
à quelque chose puis le seuil et aucune
chance qu'on s'endorme à ce moment là
exactement c'est ce qu'on note plus
dernières masses que c'est un trouble
qui augmentait avec je sais pas je sais
pas ce qu'il ya de pilon autant aussi
que 35% des gens se plaignent de mal
dormir un peu moins de la moitié de ceux
déjà son eau des vrais insomniaques donc
prendre plus que 39% dormiez trois fois
par semaine pendant trois mois où se
réveiller pendant plus de 30 minutes par
nuit
trois fois par semaine pendant trois
mois et mal fonctionné le jour à cause
de ça on mesure maintenant mieux et des
clics de sommeil comme on dit donc on le
relève plus quelques secondes pour
soigner patek un peu plus peut-être un
peu plus peut-être moins je lis soit des
taxis disent qu'on doit attendre de moi
qui est certain c'est peut-être possible
c'est naturel ou si on avait quatre
dents de plus d'embauchés à 300-400 avec
une évolution très riche enclos c'est
pas sûr mais dans l'immédiat
il ya beaucoup de gens qui se plaignent
d'un mal dorment et se plaignent de bien
des gens on se plaît de presets et au
travail de près de 7,7 à leur coupe pour
il ya un mal à être aussi peu vous dit
le soit mais c'est romain barras mettra
nous y quelque chose qui marche pour
prendre que quand on dort pas bien c'est
un peu ça met lui même qui dans bien des
codes d'enfants que je vois la clinique
c'est pas un premier sommet tant que ça
apparaisse d'anxiété un problème de
régulation des émotions un problème
d'organisation familiale dans
l'oreillette de l'environnement physique
que sortes de raisons que ce monsieur
très sensible
comme des gens voient très sensible à
cette remontée dès que c'est un p tit k
ça va mal et la toile entre nous dès
qu'on est contrarié on voit mal dormir
ou notre famille sera possible soit y
compris je me suis endormi mais je me
suis vite astarac me suis fait des
mauvais rêves jamais de mauvaise que les
quantités puis avec elle tout ça mais
aussi jeux maison pourrait dormir ne va
avoir un très mauvais sens mais qui fait
qu'on ne peut récupérer après des
analyses de données de laboratoire
plusieurs options de donner ensemble qui
montrent que dans certains écope
certaine mesure de fonctionnement la
mémoire attention tout plein de vie qui
montrent qu'une nuit fragmenté par de
multiples réveil est pire que nuit
blanche
oui et du ciment cette sas expliquerait
peut-être c'était que ce serait parce
que dans ce code fragmentation look on
avait d'autres personnes vous faites
mine est à peu près partout la nuit
juste pour une mule passera dans le
cerveau par son temps d'un état à
l'autre
ils risquent pas et à s'y faire sa job
comme si quelqu'un vous pousseront des
productions douala et ipad vous lisez
use est décrite attentivement c'est
assez d argent mais c'était un peu ce
que ça fait c'est que quand on tirait
toutes les nuits mettez dans un des
toques et pas super c'est être moins
pire que d'être d'être intervenu de
passer d'un état à l'autre tout en tout
1 tout le temps possiblement c'est à
vérifier comme seule explication que
j'avais tablé sur l'icône du puy qualité
du sommeil donc moins comme en commun
maintenant je pense je recule ont
pratiquement début la conversation à ce
qu'on perde la consolidation de la
mémoire pied du du haras rue m
comment est ce qu on maximise le sommeil
qui est qui positive comme celui là fait
qu'ils ont le sommeil qui sont les mieux
c'est
comment est ce qu'on fait pour
premièrement est ce qu'il ya une zone de
semaine
est-ce que des zones de semaine avec l
on veut être le plus souvent puis
comment est ce qu'on fait pour maximiser
ce jeu répond versa j'sais pas si près
six mois à venir et mon sommeil on veut
pas et c'est tout contrôler saison ses
impressions au temps passé des
thermomètres ça nous dit la question de
ce mécanisme et l'achat mais il se passe
dans profondément casser le thermomètre
comprend un pis si je coule terme un
vrai témoin m soit pas fait plus chaud
dehors mais c'est pareil demain je
m'envoie des zones noires
par contre c'est de savoir quelles sont
les meilleures conditions possibles pour
que je dorme bien que le lendemain matin
jeudi j'ai payé dormi pendant les
questionner de sommeil la grande
question de temps il ya cette question
qu'on peut se poser de commentaires ça
prend vite endormi
karotz couche culotte slip se parer d'un
fake semaines passent chaque semaine
avec le cadre est très vite sous bien
des questions et tu sais tu fais ton
sommeil
c'est la meilleure question qui
satisfait bien voir la carte
si je dois pas bien on va en parler si
ça va mal à réaction donc se trouver
quels sont des meilleures conditions
puis dans les bonnes conditions
ce qui manque le plus je pense c'est la
dernière demi-heure du coup chez tous
les animaux va se coucher sur audigier
des shows rock thomas roux et vos
pilotes y voir se promener de sanofi
chris par sa diplomate pour moi je ne
sais des choses à l'aide de ton d'en
face à peu près sorti
mettez y installe comme il faut un
rapport de refaire pareil on devine un
peu se redresser sans nous devrons paris
ce carnet la dernière demi heure enfin
des choses quand même quelque chose
d'inoffensif des lectures une offensive
dessiner je dis moi la peau aux enfants
que je vois pour parents que je joue à
la clinique
arrêtez de parler à votre enfant dans
d'honneur qui précède le coucher
cependant un enfant de mes 18 ans max
caron l'obsède ou demain pas super
soirée pu noter voix spin et puis j'en
ai mis au repos spéciaux afin qu'ils
retournent la journée de ce temps là
demain tête rousse calme tu peux faire
des câlins chuchoter décidément talent
fait des jetables
pas trop vu s'amener au calme et éviter
le sommeil préparer la baisse de
traitement d'information dans ta gueule
puis dégager de soap puis au sommet vont
venir que la changera accueillante à son
goût surtout pour mettre des adultes ou
des enfants ont choisi ses propres
couleurs se pressent pas vous choisi la
couleur de la chance et à votre enfant
que ce mois ci lui que pour ses 8 ans
pour vous le fait qu' il peut choisir sa
couleur puis aux peaux de vache pas
tellement dans le rouge à fait à la
famille et l'admiré fermé pour la grippe
est clair que d'aucuns disent comme il
faut donner des bonnes habitudes de
faire un qu'elles aient plus d'enfants
vieillit plus il lui conter l'histoire
paul parent qui soit en contrôle de la
situation et supporte une nouvelle
langue
ils valent au magasin que les parents
pour l'acheter s'il faut que de
nouvelles hausses
il voit choisi de tissus à la limite
tout il faut peut-être coude avec un
grand moment où grand papa ou à
quelqu'un qui va le faire les impliqués
là-dedans c'est pareil les adultes
c'est un peu comme je vais ma chambre à
coucher comment j'organise pas suivi les
conseils de tous manqué ce qui nous
plaît nous c'est pas bon pour soi quand
on voit mal dormir taxi moi je veux des
choses qui je veux des lumières mois
puis vu que ça flashe dans ma jambe
quand je marque on voit ça raconte je
dois possible la meilleure façon de le
faire c'est donc lundi comme on veut et
puis la demi heure qui précède si j'ai
plus de relance
ça promet plus de chemin et paradoxal
après tant mieux mais pas moi contrôlées
soit il ya du ca job de quelqu'un
d'autre dans mon cerveau qui fait sont
aussi d'avoir un sommet qui bien qu'ils
en même temps j'ai bien dormi et je
compte puis le soir va te coucher je
pense aux chorégies je me trompe mais
naturellement qu'un canot stedesa on
sécrète la mélatonine
si le fait que mettons maintenant chez
nous ça se paie toutes les lumières
soient allumés où ça se peut qu'on
lisent sur l'ipad en tchéquie que c'est
fait la lumière sur ça va retarder la
sécrétion et mauritanie ça va faire
comment moins bon sa mère oui
effectivement mais c'est autant ça qu'on
a blâmé beaucoup la lumière bleue ce
biais longuement le que sont l'équilibré
plus facilement la mélatonine
mais je crois beaucoup au fait du
contenu de ce qu'on lit si je
un roman assez trash que le monde
s'arrache la tête à tous et 2e ligne
si certains savoirs méfiance est bien
plus qu'avant - de mélatonine c'est que
les enfants transports sont à l'arrêt
dans leurs cauchemars d'acteurs quatre
films de peur ou est tu vas pas faire
des choses qui s'est bagarré [ __ ] vent
se coucher faute est vite le chemin est
pas très évident que des seuls dire
quelque chose
pas moi quelqu'un qui est dont le plan
de retraite et sur le placer à la bourse
puis regarde la bourre sur votre jeu
chaque soir au super bowl et les réseaux
sociaux maintenant qu'il ya du des
commentaires laissés sur hâtif qui
viennent
qu'est ce que les gens disent bon ben
moi j'ai arrêté ça commence déjà par la
rétine de l'oeil touché fait plus que la
lumière bleue dans le fond oui les 2
sont dommageables gauche pas de contenu
énorme amour et pense pas ça mais je
pense est très très très important donc
quand on lit moi je le fais mes flèches
de patience trois jours solitaire je mon
téléphone
vous aimerez la bunge écoute la musique
de film relaxe lors que j'écoute c'est
ainsi il pleuvait des oiseaux
la musique de soi est super bonne est un
des couples qui ont fait ce sont des
ménages en abitibi mais transfère la
musique c'est super coup c'est
tranquille j'écoute soit puis je m'en
vais en traitement de quelqu'un c'est
pas bon faire soit par sa musique
arrêtent pendant libre ça sonne la date
il y avait quelque chose il avait eu un
enfant venant du temps qu'ils passent
pas dans mon comme moi puis docteur
semaine je le dois je le fais ça
fonctionne dit je vois jouer pour injure
que la lumière tamisée un peu vous ça
fonctionnait pas j'ai pas de premier
deux semaines je prends une somme n'est
mentionné saugnac on recommence le
processeur du département droit chez
moisson est très ouvert au spi le reste
a dit ceci ouais c'est bien correct et
tu dors bien c'est bien quand même avoir
commencé réapprendre à marcher comme une
rééducation et réadaptation va prendre
direct à la base on va voir jusqu'où
aller dans ton corps bouteille une bonne
nuit de sommeil
oui tu peux l'aider à faire cela et pas
de potes problème certains contenus
comme le cirque les enfants c'est très
plaisant
c'est vrai pour tout le monde donc on va
définir une autre manne des paramètres
qui font ça qu'il a même un terme au
dessus j'ai passé une bonne mystérieux
jeu
j'entendais aussi que de garder une
bonne relation avec l'espace dans lequel
on dort c'est quelque chose qui est
super important puisse à elle ça pouvait
aller jusqu'à si on était dans ton lit
n'était pas capable de t'endormir parce
que tu en sais quelque chose sorte de
tâche en vo dans le salon existe au lit
un livre pour que tu as aussi encore le
lit comme étant en droit positif et non
l'endroit négatif c'est une des
composants d'intervention pour
l'insomnie qu'on parle de beaucoup de
thérapies cognitivo-comportementales ça
veut dire soit que cette thérapie l'eau
fait pas des psychologues surtout la
jauge éphémère diplôme ils peuvent faire
valoir
donc c'est de dire pour cognitif dans
les comptes relié mythe conduct moi ça
me prend absolument 11 heures pour avoir
une bonne nuit est ce que c'est vrai ce
raisonnable on voit fait
l'expérimentation bien sûr de façon
déterminée les croyances toucheront
tapas comportementale qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire pour faire voir ce que cela
donne 1 2 milliard dont on vient de
parler et il ya toutes sortes de petites
options qu'on rajoute à ça par exemple
dans le lit le lit et doit être réservé
quelqu'un qui dort mal qui fait de
l'insomnie les réseaux 3 change dormir
ce soir quand on est malade et activités
sexuelles
seul ou avec dans ses trois sauts j'ai
rien d'autre au liban on mange pour capa
tv qu'on réfléchisse pour planifier
parier si c'est autre chose on sort du
lit puis on va donc le choix d'aller
ailleurs la maison la défendre mais
c'est d'avoir un big bag h entre danse
et d'incohérences et silos pour
m'exprimer à tamiser rouge pour
feuillette un magazine jour de
l'offensive regard des recettes de
cuisine ou en garde a dit selim nabous
dacquois qui adore les mains paragraphe
4 fois ce qu'on commence à s'en donner
pour toi ce projet pilote à petrov
toronto coucher ça recommence après dix
minutes tortul bean bags ça recommençait
5 à 5 fois hyper tough après 3,4 nuit le
savoy fini par comprendre
ok là bas alors c'est carey que je le
ferai plus calme maintenant des rois
dormait parfois c'est à faire autrement
puis d'autres occupations faut apprendre
à les faire à l'air aussi fin qu'un
autre genre de technique c'est que tu
prends ton moment mauritania canton
moment de soucis
did you kiss me dis je me retiens puis
pense que c'est qu'ils mènent à papier
crayon au clavier est écrit voici ce qui
m'énerve macroscopiquement dans
l'univers ou dans ma vie personnelle
aussi tes écrits puis régis hip hop
c'est fait
quand ça revient de soi non demain à
midi je vais m'en occuper encore on
organise sont un produit ce qu'est ce
qu'on fait comment callies les espaces
la chance est fait pour dormir se
soigner avoir d'activité sexuelle pas
pour d'autres choses
on veut manger cet arrière d'ici là que
des adolescents mais leurs chances et de
repères il manque du travail téléphone
fontaine a fermé parce que pour la paix
et non pas des parents des gens qui font
leur univers dans son si dort bien pas
de problème si on est rendus indications
d'hygiène publique c'est autre chose
sari perez à l'occuper c'est un enfant
qui dorment à crédin sony là on repart à
zéro qu'on va les voir jusqu'au palais
puis tu as et je fais des accommodements
raisonnables
oui tu peux garder et à la fin on voyait
petit à petit à petit on fait par
petites petites étapes ça fonctionne
bien pour des adolescents c'est surtout
tengiz lui va décider par lui d'y jouer
qu'est ce qu'il veut faire qu'est ce
qu'il veut comme mesures qu'ils prennent
un soin que je commencerai mois toto tu
ne dois jamais désarmé
gérard géron on peut soit travaillé sur
l'heure du lever le matin des fins de
semaine où on peut travailler sur
l'activité que sûrement te coucher puis
voici qu'est ce que t'as pas présent
dans le kop dans l'aude par contre je
n'ai commencé puisque d'audi des dix
mois les pieds pendant un petit peu puis
abusivement des tutos de solution ça
fonctionne déjà un peu mieux parce
qu'ils étaient impliqués dans son
approche qui évoque les indispensables
surtout des enfants pour les tout petits
les enfants qui ont associé donc à
passer de raisonner sont capables de
participer péter à contacter accompagné
par an souvent moi si je fais la partie
comportementale à des crises en fente à
pacy coloniser des parents non votre
enfant pas seulement besoin de dormir de
9h30 tas qui a besoin petit peu moins de
dormir ou non il est pas obligé de jouer
aux lego pendant qu'ils mènent tous les
soirs à 7h people with me ne peut pas
jouer ce soir ne s'étonne pas si fatigué
l'attaqué malades par an comme ce que je
vois que sont autistes quattro déficit
d'attention qui sont anxieux fin de la
journée sont aussi fatigués que nous
autres puis parfois plus ont travaillé
fort toute la journée c'est comprendre
qu'est ce qu'on attend
qu'est ce que je dois faire à se faire
et il dépassé beaucoup les enfants ont
trop de bateaux soient intimes des
bouées l'école le soir sont fatigués
l'épisode peuvent pas prendre un verre
de scotch à soyaux se détend et on rien
d'autre que soi qui m'a dit pas rajouter
parce qu'un enfant fatigué c'est
irritable et puis c'est ça court partout
s'obstine d'abord comme tout autant que
nous on le fait quand il rentre à bari
ce que jamais l'envié pas bon donc
pourrait certes pas ça tout le monde à
s'organiser a décidé à faire sopi toute
la question est ce que sommeil
satisfaisant le lendemain on a trouvé le
chemin pour commencer quelques
kilomètres des zones où on retrouve le
sommet important comme en ce début
voici les règles assez strictes
maintenant où est ce qu'on peut se
donner de la marge de manoeuvre pour
voir un mois j'avais moi j'avais si j'ai
fait de la natation de compétition
pendant longtemps puis j'ai pris des
habitudes par exemple de mettre des
bouchons de dormir avec des bouchons
parce que quand je t'ai
qu'un condamné en compétition deux mots
sinon j'ai avec moi qui reconnaît en
compétition tout le temps qu'ils gagnent
en chant qui ronfle qui fait des bruits
talent avec moi j'ai pris l'habitude de
mettre des bouchons plus éventuellement
j'ai plus l'habitude de mettre quelque
chose pour courir le loup est un loup
pour couvrir parce que j'ai pris j'ai
commencé parce que les bouchons étaient
plus assez parce que le cac avait un
petit bruit je me réveillais et je garde
ça met une machine qui fait des white
noise là à côté de mon lit
le chum en mode caché dans ma chambre
si je suis ailleurs que dans ma chambre
j'ai pas tout suivi aucune chance que je
dorme comme du monde sait comment je
fais pour faire comme comme vous disiez
puis revenez au début de fer qui le veut
je joue être capable de dormir à quelque
part ça sent que je me réveille à chaque
fois qu'il ya un mini bruit ou 5 à
chaque fois qu'un petit peu de lumière
je me réveille du possible c'est de
faire un genre de genre de we7 dirait
safa la thérapie un peu de casse de
thérapie je dirais d'abord étape par
étape petit et par petites étapes en
commençant par la fin de la soirée
d'avoir cette demi-heure l'eau de
déployer des quelque 200 disponible
c'est quand même ça va mal être est
moindre ce moment le kent conrad soyez
au moins la scène amy qui puisse y avoir
du soleil
après on peut travailler sur le reste
une chose à la fois puis c'est ce que tu
décris comme instinct sauvage ci a
politiquement qu'il faut voir c'est le
sevrage puis ça va puisque logique ça
existe pour juste la pilule elle même si
le fait de l'apprendre sanou sécurisé
par ce même si rayonnant pilule effet
placebo les bouchons c'est vrai que ça
sert que les appuis vélos d'un moment à
l'autre mediamath puceau serov pour un
site c'est avant taxes faut aller
progressivement trouve qu est-ce que
plus accommodant petit peu faut faire le
tour du jardin aussi ce que l'agent mais
qu'aurait qu'est ce que c'est
parfaitement obscur très bien obscures
est-ce que c'est silencieuse la
température est bonne pas trop chaud pas
trop voir on dit au taux de 19,6 vert
autour d'eux
un peu plus haut mais plus frais un peu
l'été donne en effet ce parc à bouaye de
l'humidité il en a eu assez climatisés
dont le bruit tout ce que cette
agression d'un vent favorable
est ce qu'il ya des objets de travail
qui traînent dans charme si oui on les
couches avec les enfants qui avaient six
mois soit maintenant mais quelques
années avec des ordis dans les jambes a
brillé lors dis pas que faire trouver un
bout de tissu à tes parents choisi le
puits soit soit couché ton ordi comme
étant toujours couché ton téléphone je
peu fébrile cette enveloppe à tes
parents se mettre dedans puisque
beaucoup dormir le téléphone ou le ipod
tu me sur ce côté ils votent pas loin
mais tu le ferment tout soit pas là
comme ce qu'elle pensait du sevrage
appuie les appareils se mêlent pots de
pilules pulver de costumes trempés
la fois d'après le vert d'où est plein
et douillet n'a pas d'appareil dans
salle de bain pour quoi comme ça c'est
fait étape par étape petit à petit mais
sûrement à personne on va choisir la
pensée quelques semaines assez bien
fonctionné puis pourquoi maintenant à ce
qui est moche comme ce puits mettant lui
il peut dormir partout n'importe où
n'importe quel projet ça c'est parce que
moi maintenant là en avion le j'aurais
jamais un sommeil je serai jamais
capable de me laisser partir
quand un avion lui et en avion et
n'importe où les explications soient que
des privés de sommeil piqué titre à
travers des cta de chance de le faire
s'est passé soit que tu est assez calme
tu peux dormir un peu soit que toi tu
étais plus nerveux ton battements
cardiaques baisse pas ses billes et
aperçoit s'inquiète pas espoir qui est
toujours un peu les antennes sortie puis
voit beaucoup d'impact et que ça comme
ça pour les antennes sortie d'un cas de
cette loterie
j'aurai des fûts j'ai l'impression que
oui parce que c'est pas rares mais tant
que je dors puis que là je me réveille
un peu un terreurs nocturnes je pense
que ça s'appelle tic que je me réveille
avec avec un mode il ya quelque chose
qui s'est passé quelque chose qui passe
et plus le genre mon coeur mes
pulsations et spike puis le pied dans la
porte qui suit entendu le père allemand
c'est comme rien ce spectacle sont pas
de panique mais d'un réflexe
d'orientation l'étaient les antennes
sortie terrain d'auxerre décrypte
j'ai fait ce tir saman le nom l'ont
récemment j'ai commencé à faire ce
western et colloques l'upi sachant petit
était dans une autre salle de pittis ça
m'est arrivé plusieurs fois je l'entends
pays a décrié le décrier fort à manier
chez tht aussi à l'extérieur j'entre
dans une maison qui ont trait musique
puis j'ai réveillé de la maison en
criant puis justement puis j'ai
l'impression que j'ai été aussi dans la
force de ce sommet où est ce que le
corps est paralysée parce que je voulais
me réveiller je tapais capable de bouger
le chevalier puisqu'il y est mais ça
c'est autre chose un peu c'est une des
choses se faire tuer pour finir le cope
h il ya déjà qu'ils ont donc la somme
est fragile comme des gens qui ont petit
à petit et gros sabine sicaud locaux
comme on est comme ça on devient
indépendant j'ai pas trop d une chose
qui peut aider par l'envié d'apprendre à
faire la relaxation pendant journée en
général des gens actifs comme ça en live
ça va être une peu de relaxation que je
vous ai envoyé des palmiers et de
relaxation qui va être pompée le
psychomotricien d'induire le contrat
centre d'attention que la détente avec
souvent s'appelle si tu cherches sur
internet ça va taper jacobsson pour l
accès tropicaux motrices puis et des
formules vraiment bref qu'on peut faire
trois fois par jour pendant trois
minutes c'est de serrer ses points puis
déjeuner cela représente 3 secondes et
dessert six secondes mettant depuis à
présent du compte un de trop pour le
disert jusqu'à 6 seconde partie des 104
que sa ferrari mais pourquoi tu veux
faire mon temps libre contre comme
soulever des haltères
comme si et puis tu auras différents
sont un peu puis je sors satin dassault
rafale à 10 ans entre temps dupuy peau
tendue t'as quand arrive le soir c'est
pas de surprise depuis ce temps du cc
quoique de la preuve au regard de co2
chercher la détente
sapin la pratique du fenspiride ça peut
être la bonne façon on prend par les
puces
or donc imprécis mais ça existe à ce
papier pour être passé pas très
différent
par contre ça sedan qui parle là c'était
plus problème avec moi dit monsieur qui
nous attend c'est pas si rare que ça
consomme est paradoxal on est paralysé
le sauver ou horaires se met près
d'auxerre puis se mêlant ça se déroule
tous les stades de sommeil lent profond
ce n'est pas que 70 à 90 mais de peu à
peu près puisque cette période se répète
toutes les nuits donc on est un bloc de
90 minutes qui se répète
1 2 3 4 se méprend ducks à d'autres
occasions et paradoxale au début d'année
beaucoup sommet profond vraiment profond
où est-ce qu'on respire lentement
nous on s'est réparti père lance
vraiment en hibernation le fesman et on
n'aime plus la nuit avance - en dessous
donc proportion de 90 minutes et plus en
plus petit
puis que la nuit avance plus ce même
paradoxal parce qu'on rêve tous sont
certes pas sont actives on est paralysé
ça ça prend de la place en nageant plage
un pub c'est avant tout la mise
ce qui fait que en début de nuit on peut
faire des réveils qui sont accompagnés
de ce qu'on appelle des parrains somni
des choses qu'on n'aurait pas faire
pendant la nuit normalement par les
marchés marché jeu qui grincent des
dents tout ce qu on aurait pour faire
soit normalement pendant 1000 ça se
produit en sommeil lent profond parce
qu'on se réveille un peu et puis tout
mon respect pour les personnes qui sont
somnambule et comme le poulet patates on
est cerveau encore un nombre très landes
complètement déconnecté on peut faire
des gestes est si précis on peut allumer
son ordi le lancer mettre le mot de
passe puis d'autres méfaits des nounous
rida dessus de effacer des fichiers de
la fois comme ça on peut prendre sa
voiture qui l'a conduit la sortir du
garage ou de la lie dans la rue il ya
chaque année où à chaque deux ans un
acte de violence qui a été posée par
l'accueil que pour savoir ce qui était
quelque part fin aux violences à s'en
rendre compte
puis avec cécilia stars comme expliquer
mais on peut on peut comprendre la cbc
vrai c'est pas ça se passe en début de
nuit jeudi réveil incomplet pour pousser
jusqu'à vers la fin de la nuit doit se
produire soit des cauchemars donc pour
l'enfant arrive tellement est à même
hauteur que ça nous réveille
les mâles bien aussi simplement le fait
de se rendre compte qu'on est paralysé
on voudrait parler de son pot dans un mr
fonctionne pas pour les super mal c'est
une paralysie de sommeil c'est comme si
on sortait de sommeil paradoxal
sauf la paralysie panique à moi c'est
paniquant puis on passe alors ça ça puis
ses parents une grande classe de sommeil
faut avoir soigné 40 étudiants présents
dans la salle
il a toujours un ou deux qui va voir
après que quelque chose comme ça c'est
pas ça marche des fois ça apparaît
c'était une chirurgie de l'anesthésié
générale et d'échoppés sont passés peu
avant soit d'autre personne dans la
famille l'ont fait monsieur déjà qu'ils
sont très très somnolent dans la famille
parce que ça fait partie d'une maladie
somme il s'appelle la narcolepsie un art
que les psys ceux de maladies qui car il
faisait paraître très très très salll
donnant à voir des attaques de sommeil
subite avec des six aces qui dure
vraiment pas très longtemps que l'on
très rafraîchissante policier du nord 10
mai de 15 8% qu'est ce que c'est
possible avec des ailes destination iep
nago logique c'est des hallucinations
quand on sent dans l'hypnose s'endormir
au sens d'or puis on est comme en double
conscience je sais que suis réveillé il
ya vraiment une araignée géante qui
manque d'en face où ils ne seront que
sanguine à mon front on y révèle en même
temps tout ça ça crée des symptômes d'un
marco des primes des foyers apparaissent
tout seul mode est paralysé je connais
une famille où est ce que la mère et la
fille
on présentera des parasites sommeil
c'est des fois ça veut dire que
disparaît pour le pus je sais pas
qu'est-ce qui contrôle sur mobile est
sympa quand on est stressé ou caen
compte des changements de routine qui
sommeil lent profond mouvement parasite
sommeil je sais pas moi c'était vraiment
des cauchemars en fait qui est allé
doucement contenu terrifiant canada
famille aussi créé sur moi je ne tente
comme à nantes à la pêche qui s'apprête
à retrouver puis à l'écrit par réveiller
tout le monde dans ce chalet bien
contenu les sports c'est l'histoire que
je me souviens qu est ce qui se passait
moi c'est comme si moi j'essaie d'en
sortir plus à manille jarryd en espèces
des trucs un peu entre les deux le gel
si je peux pas bouger mais j'étais
encore un peu d'amour à amman et je mets
des prend mais l'espèce d'un moment ce
qui est je peux pas bouger parce que je
veux me réveiller il suffirait quelqu'un
te touche du bout du doigt tous très
hâte en sortant c'est vraiment un
fascinant sahara antennes et confient
leur ca mais mon épouse a déjà montré
son aussi bien vrai j'ai jamais comme un
effet de la part même si rondes qui
rendent en trompant main juste y toucher
à peine de s'asseoir dessus
puis j'ai parié il va se retourner de
bar puis je checke avoir tombé dedans
sont peu retombée d'un coup et karakar
pub ça retombe donnant leur avis sur
l'hadopi mais ça fait beaucoup plus
rarement mais sa survie et que je sois
dans des familles ça peut arriver
effectivement on sait qu'un arc haut
débit elle même si juridiquement
déterminé partie le lait petit jeu c'est
pas trop vite donnés par rapport à soi
ça existe patron aussi que c'est pas si
grave que sommes déjà c'est moins
dramatique pour aussi que ces français
areva
moi aussi que c'est ce à quoi peut
s'entendre il est prévu que ça arrive je
ferai à la fin je sais que pour les
paras chemises débiles annie combes
hypno la commune tout comme le
somnambulisme base à l'hypnose
fonctionne non plus avec un vrai terreau
a pas eu de l'ethnologue la voiture au
pied prochaine fois que la nuit soit
réveillé toi mais depuis atteint soit
réveillé puis ça fonctionne très bien
pas tant que ça fonctionnerait les fadas
même si prochaine fois que je me sente à
l'aise et plus je me réveillais que ça
d'être comme ça marche qu'est ce qui se
passe c'est le pire cauchemar m'étais un
peu comme est question de ce début
pourquoi pourquoi honda
pourquoi on rêve qui à quoi ça sert puis
qu'est ce qui se passe dans cerveau
comme une fonction du rayo la théorie
mais d'abord faut commencer par des
ottomans qui s'appelle de ses rêves à
peu près il ya des gens qui s'appellent
régulièrement de rhein hâte après un
siècle sans appel jamais peu près ça que
ce rappel
les théories de ça des théories du rêve
dont les premières théories plus
scientifique du rand gilbert c'est
sigmund freud grand psychanalyste au
tournant du siècle précédent des 10900
publié sur les rives pioche maps puis
lui disais nous réservent à évacuer des
tensions condos mais de façon déguisée
au plus pressé vous et qu'on veut tuer
maintenant on veut pas s'avouer court
est bon qu'il faut ou non mais bon on
peut pas s'avouer sorte qu'ils l'avouent
l'étude
on peut pas donc on va diviser se
pourvoira est vécu comme on a beau un
arbre ou que vous que quand on mange un
steak saignant nous a menti on voit
sublimer son temps d'usinage puisque sa
saga saw parce que ce n'est acceptable
xavier trou inacceptable là c'est votre
super a dit que tu avais moi je fais mon
effort mais je peux plus déguisées ça on
savait s'attaque aux gens pour rêver
c'est trop trouvant pour cette théorie
est pour qu on a des recettes et lofo à
dire l intérêt qu on est inconscient
maintenant que c'est inconscient alors
créé des symboles qui me dire quelque
chose aux pics de la théorie freudienne
utilisant un dictionnaire des symboles
terry freudienne à 10h à 15h symbole
puis le petit canal et c'est ce qui fait
voici de me remettre à la conscience que
ça veut dire chaque affaire un oreiller
pour tous que ça veut dire que tout le
réseau que ça veut dire
les autres théories d'autres les prés de
thierry durel jeunes un kit est vraiment
extrême qui dit les rsa juste pas de
sens c'est juste nous ne rogne qui font
du fric game
j'allais à des images de cette eau de
puisserguier not so puis au milieu
évidemment comme d'habitude il y aura un
petit peu des deux puis c'est un europe
ce qui a repris canalis qui a dit ben
est un petit peu des deux et des raisons
de cerveaux responsables de générer des
images puis autour d' évidence pour ça
qu'on va chez notre mémoire
qu'est ce qui nous préoccupe on voit ces
images là pour les véhiculer ce qui fait
que pierre plutôt quand on rêve on n'a
pas de jugement par ces régions front
certains des régions frontales sont
actives qu'on n'a pas de jugement taxi
un camion qui vient devant auxerre qui
me parlent sa voix de ma grand mère je
pense y est un ex haut moi c'est ça la
dérange il peut se passer de la fac
complètement incroyable tu fais ça
parce qu'on n'a pas ce juge balogh cto
d'alphonse allais fonctionne par
installer au cerveau qui sont très
actives le très très mais moi émotions
ça fonctionne et un plan que même plus
que éveillé non je devrais pas le dire
je sais plus ce que ça fonctionne
vraiment beaucoup le parce que on peut
pas faire plus parce que les entrepôts
fait pareil mais ça fonctionne ça qui
comme paul c'est lui qui fait lors dans
tous ceux de lui toucher les autres vire
complètement fou d'être observé ben oui
pis new york times parce qu'on rêve des
choses qui nous préoccupe qui nous
intéresse ce sera la journée soit 4,6
dans notre journée qu'on s'est passé se
dépêtrer vingt mois sept nuits chaudes
nuits est ravi aux texans parce que
beaucoup de moi parce que souvent mois
mettant l'intérêt dans les théories que
vous exposez de dire que c'est juste
n'importe quoi
si les neurones qui s'affolent mais ça
fait pas de sens parce que des fois il
ya des rêves qui sont tellement qui tue
quelqu'un quand tu te réveilles tu te
rappelles tu es prêt c'est sûr je
rêvasse c'est ce qui s'est passé hier
puis c'est sur ce site est il facile de
transposer ça m'a dit qu'on était des
fois ce jeudi deux éléments c'est dans
une pièce nous préoccuper pendant la
journée on va incorporer ça dans un
objet connu pendant un mois je regarde
un film puis film sur l'équitation mais
je suis préoccupé par la correction des
examens des étudiants par exemple
ben je peux voir un cheval qui fait des
éditions sur une calculette et c'est à
moi de trouver que ça veut dire c'est
quoi ce pas un symbole c'est une
imagerie puisqu'il un peu comme quand on
y rend les coûts de la musique ou
d'impression figurer au tibet musique
est en fait c'est du cas par cas et
c'est pareil pour le rêve c'est une
peinture aussi quelque chose qu'on
projette là-dessus ce qu'on a nos
émotions notre mémoire pour ça que quand
pendant toi tu te réveilles va vite est
paralysé tavin vrai comme tout le monde
en fait puis tout est maintenant
rencontrer réveiller un petit peu ça
peut faire penser aussi aux gens qu'on
dise qu'on appelle des rêves lucides des
gens qui sont en train de rêver ils
savent qui restent sont capables de
contrôler
c'est une option que tu peux acheter en
plus aimés déjà de 30 compte que tuer
des gens qui te font people de signer à
lille par exemple en laboratoire ont dit
ok quand soit faire un rêve tant
rencontre bush 18 parce qu'on sait
qu'ils peuvent bouger dans gotti du 4 x
à droite deux fois à gauche il a fondu
est en train de vie si nous il s'était
montré plusieurs points qui s'entendait
double conscience comme ce que tu disais
tantôt suscité tant ils le font puis
contrôlé contenu soit c'est une option
en plus que je peux prendre que oui les
gens peuvent le faire on peut
l'apprendre à le faire un pli de fins de
contrôle de ses rêves ou pousser
apprivoiser contenu le débit des
peuplades où des tribus eau des cultures
où est ce qu'ils se réunissent tous les
matins y laisser notre entraînement
venus le matin puis par des rails puis
les enfants qui rêvent que 10 kg tomber
moi je trouvais pendant lithium est en
zone on est en train d'apprendre voit
les gens sont contre rappelez vous ce
qu'est ce qu'on fait des cauchemars
on répète cauchemar pour trouver une
issue plus agréable je j'entendais aussi
qu'il y avait une chercheuse aux états
unis qui avaient réussi à créer des
rêves
l'étude tend à donner un problème à ses
étudiants qui mettait à côté de leur lit
puis en s'endormant il penser aux
problèmes piquant dans deux comme trois
semaines
le problème prenez part au ras et il
était capable de résoudre le problème
que d'arriver avec une réponse à travers
l'europe - deux aspects sur wii puis à
plusieurs choses qui se font comme ça un
petit peu comment pu enfin une moi même
mes intérêts dans ton sommeil ça a
commencé comme ça j'étais au bac
un deuxième année de bac à ottawa et
puis le prof
c'est joseph de koninck un prof qui est
super c'est du rêve et du sommeil à
ottawa et puis il avait permis deux
collègues depuis moins de faire des
expériences dans son laboratoire et pour
laisser d'influencer le contenu des
rêves d'un homme qui dormait au labo
pendant fin de semaine qu'on chantait
des chansons de noël puis passeront pas
le réveiller bosse avec 6,1 corde pour
qu'elles sont nées ces règles enfin
peut-être un marché ne fait pas une
autre fait partie des prêts ce qui est
versé champ visuel pour la loi ce qui
est râlant
l'autre toute la journée aussi pendant
une journée voire sainte florence rey
puis c'était mes premiers étaient
effectivement ça toujours été sur
comment on peut influencer le contenu
direct pensant dans certains cox elle
aiderait à résoudre des problèmes j'ai
pas certain que ça marche n'est pas
certain que cela lui il ya même des
compagnies publicitaires
budweiser qui essaient de faire cela
d'influencer les rêves des gens là c'est
à nantes en confessant donc d'effacer
contenu des rêves sa flotte le contenu
qu'on autour de nouvelles français
nouerait vos boîtes et incorporer c'est
certain de résoudre un problème
moi je vous jure que je résoudrai puis
en sortes d'anecdotes qui ont retrouve
toujours les lives qui coulerait qui
étaient les chercheurs à l'époque je
trouvais la structure moléculaire du
benzène qui est un genre de dano
atteints de fa cela arrive est certain
que ce mort des incultes il ya bien du
monde contrefaire des os découverts dans
l'enquêté révélera journée le crédit des
add ons l'a un peu il ya plus serré du
souvent et donc de fait exercice là
c'est peut-être vrai c'est peut-être
vrai mais c'était pas une solution repas
déjà dans les années 1970 son ex-époux
d'apprendre des langues pendant qu'on
dort et grands parents contre les 3 4
maudeux serbe que le père ne peut
apprendre mais a été réveillée pendant
saab l'avis des gens de rêver
on savait que ça marche pas très bien
que ce n'est pas par contre à prendre
pendant condat c'est une chose mais
comme on disait plutôt le sommeil c'est
le team est en moi moche miss yen à la
vie plm est vraiment aperçu que pour
intégrer des nouvelles pièces que
j'apprenais le sommeil de la meilleure
manière le typique énorme et dormir est
vraiment hippie je me rendais compte sur
steam et ont même été j'avais un
contre-feu à chaque semaine est quand
même groupe pied chaque semaine on se
donne une nouvelle d'une belle chanson
qu'on apprenne été souvent interpellé la
dame et on se dit c'est la veille je me
rendais compte que mettons un quinze
minutes avant de coucher que j'apprends
la nouvelle chanson je me couche là
dessus le lendemain je la savais par cas
ça va super bien versus je pouvais la
sphère la regarder une à la journée même
tyran du soir pour faire mon show des
fois je m'en souvenais [ __ ]
le fait d'avoir dormi entre les deux
c'est vraiment look et que j'ai intégré
complètement c'était ma soeur le superbe
ou protocoles de recherche
c'est exactement ce que les chercheurs
faire c'est en plein saut s'est comparé
le passage du temps où fait de dormir
j'ai dit dans mon laboratoire café ce
même genre de travail lent donc de deux
d'apprendre à reconnaître vin au visage
par exemple le soir une heure après on
leur demande encore des reconnaître puis
le lendemain après la nuit sommeil ont
passé des sommets c'est vrai visage
appui 20 autres en bout si tout mélanger
pilote béthune pitt ont posé dessus ce
que l'étude que suppose le visage non
puis on fait la même affaire mais deux
jours donc le matin même aux choses non
aux diviseurs pipita plus tard on garde
ce qu'ils font mais y apprennent bay
mieux viser choses là s'ils ont dormi
entre les deux que si on était rêvée
passé huit heures messe à céret pas
certaines supporte de mémoire les mots
qu'on appel explicite qui ont aussi
c'est quoi tu sais comment je progresse
pas toujours victor simoes que tu as
médité et doit vous c'est quoi le bit
c'est quoi la mesure de son c'est
explicite les choses qui sont explicites
par exemple devenir meilleur en planche
à neige devenir meilleur dans un truc
qui ne veut pas dire comment faire pour
être meilleur à prendre leur vélo quand
il s'y met c'est en équilibre pédales
quand tu viens my heart ou pas expliqué
pourquoi tu te dire mais tu t'améliores
ça c'est moins sensibles au sommet c'est
plus sensibles au passage du temps vous
n'avez pas d'histoire de mémoire parce
que c'est vraiment dix ans à turin mais
c'est tout à fait vrai fuite a fait
protocole wi chercheurs et moi car je me
suis rendu compte de ce qu'ils 15
minutes puis ultimate est plus efficace
qu'une heure de pratique la journée même
je fais c'est tellement plus efficace et
simple chemise étudiants quand les
examens réussis sur 8 pour sita nuit à
dormir que place jusqu'à 80 des visages
si la performance et mahias dormi c'est
sur ce sujet réseau puis l'autre
question que j'avais
les rêves prémonitoires c'est dessus
quelque chose qui est étudié où ces
réseaux tercica on ne sait pas où ça
c'est rien les deux jeunes anciens
collègues bain ou collègues est plus
vieux que moi l'homme qui a écrit un
livre sur sur les rêves prémonitoires
il ya pas d europe dreamhouse tingaud
qui en anglais et en ontario
et puis depuis qui est jeune qui
collectent dirais tu regarde ce qui se
passe après puis bon salaire un marché
un peu moi je peux convaincu de son jeu
pas convaincu mais avec unité à ce que
je comprends pas comment ça pourrait
marcher coin je vois pas comment ça
pourrait marcher sinon que quand on dort
pas mal quand on rêve mais quand on dort
on peut on peut distinguer les
accessoires de l'essentiel du 4 11
courses endormi c'est ce qui se passe si
on se laisse aller les choses qui sont
sages et vous importantes vont remonter
à la surface puis on va pas s'endormir
c'est trop énervant pouvoir s'endormir
c'est quelque chose qui est agréable un
petit peu mais le bruit de fond lui
basques signalent igad commençons le lit
de signal reste important qu'il brille
de folie basse saxe près de samaa les
rives qui font en sorte si de dégager ce
qui est essentiel pour trouver la
solution
c'est comme quand on recherche le nom de
quelqu'un bien on sait pas s'il pleut on
part on s'envoie tourné au jeu d'un
poids de la csn non parce que on doit
laisser faire
puis de bruit de fond puis la réponse
nous vient ainsi de se détendre ou de ne
pas faire attention que c'est ce qui
donne la réponse qu'ils soient des
retraits -3 je pense plutôt que le
travail se fait déjà et compris la nuit
puis qu'on le voit la dépendance
aujourd'hui ce fait le travail je fais
autant qu'il faudrait avoir des
protocoles préparation mais est ce que
est ce que l'analyse la symbolique ou de
l'aide de la simulation d'erreur est une
discipline qui est sérieuse
scientifiquement ou pas vraiment ce
qu'est ce que c'est vraiment quelque
chose qu'il recherchait yoyo pelouse 2-2
gauche le contenu dry contenu explicite
puis contenu latent le contenu explicite
il y avait un cheval qui me parlait puis
la mer est à montante pitt avait une
fille qui maudit vue sur un bacchus
monchal soit ces contenus explicites
puis contenu latent c'est que c'est que
ça veut dire ah ben là moi je rêve
d'aller pas des vacances et à 10 est
confiné puis vous raconterai une fille
pas voir les faits d'équitation avec ce
symbole ultime de l'équitation liberté
c'est sa liberté liberté avec quelqu'un
sait ce que ça veut dire que tu es
besoin petite frustration que tout ça
alors le contenu explicite lui pas mal
de travail ceux là dessus j'ai un
collègue qui a publié un livre sur les
rêves leur en donne au hadra qui les
publieraient sur un livre sur les rêves
qu'ils exploraient plus un vrai que
collègue claude méric est qui et qui
repart même un peu tout c'est tous ces
revenus là mais le contenu latent lui y
a pas tellement de recherche qui sur le
dessus mais si tu te dis assez en
clinique par ses mandants les
psychanalystes qui s'en servent quand
même pendant mais pas par d'autres
approches aussi puis des fois ça peut
être intéressant déjà qui verbalisent -
leurs émotions tout sur mon père mais
pas moi d'avoir des terrestre que cette
fois peut-être sera trouvée le des
dépôts des choses qui se répètent des
thèmes qui se répètent de super explorer
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour toi ce
genre de chose qui serait pas trop tout
le temps dans les pas la prémonition on
est dans l'explication de ce qu'ils
pensent mais de façon un peu maquillée
jeux maquillage là c'est pas un symbole
préformés davance freud disait des fois
un cigare c'est un cigare ça peut être
bien d'autres choses aussi tu trouves
est aperçu que ça veut dire que nos
petits retrouvez le sur cette fameuse
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui me dérange
une situation qui sont inconfortables
donc on peut travailler là dessus on
peut travailler sur les cauchemars par
exemple répétant ce cauchemar lors de
l'écriture une issue différente ici donc
je répète je trouvais un autre qu un
cauchemar qui revient quand on est
justement c'est un cauchemar qui revient
c'est est capable après ceux de mettre
sur papier ou de concrètement expliqué
comment tu aimerais que le cauchemar se
termine ce transfert aux jeunes qu'il ou
elle importe la personne à l'équipe et à
l'accueil d'un certain entourage pixon
tu peux aussi band avant que ça n'a fait
que des cauchemars pendant deux jours
faire des pochettes de rats et vivre à
écrire deux bouts de grand papa j'ai
rêvé que j'ai beaucoup de câbles et rêvé
que je vais le 9 juin soit sous l'arcade
je vois arriver à ça cette nuit c'est
plus court si peter un peu l'histoire du
gauche mais je peux aussi interrompre
les cauchemars sachant que chaque fois
soit des disputes d'après s'est réveillé
après ces deux couches et 60 et 515 me
dit fais un cauchemar
belle soirée vient de perdre c'est comme
ça une course et cuda patente gère et
développe plus au pied c'est c'est
correct pour une plainte parce que
jamais l'homme au petit matin c'est
petit si l'eau mais tu peux donc
intéressés par le contenu l'attend
contenu manifeste ont comme explique
james est manifeste
on dit souvent c'est deux choses
différentes en thérapie on s'est
beaucoup de opus avait beaucoup de
contenu comme il est inconnu mais de fès
oui la recherche pour savoir à quoi les
genres avec des hommes des femmes selon
la chambre la culture dont le revenu
j'ai trop besoin de contrôler un pull
notre sous culture un peu comme un cas
semaine faisant dire à m
puis le rôle que se joue soit comprend
une position qui dit ben on voit exprimé
de l'inavouable dans nos oreilles comme
on parlait tout à l'heure ce que freud
exprimer est-ce que ça c'est encore la
route série le scientifique mans
aujourd'hui ça se prouve pop sans
contredit paul puis encore beaucoup de
psychanalystes qui servent de s'offrent
les doigts pour quelque chose qui
fonctionne ou non
sinon moi je vois le rêve comme étant un
genre de challenge qu'on a régulièrement
pour le faire nous habituer à faire face
à l'adversité sa part la recherche
animale non plus legault qui découvrait
serait paradoxal en france qui avait
découvert plus de l'atonie musculaire le
manque de tonus mais cela ne ferait donc
sur des champs puis a fait des 10/10
d'experts soit ce qui paralyse et
inhiber la région qui nous paralyse ne
serait paradoxal tacler jacques métais
annie miller heywang il mérite en somme
est paradoxal avait des gestions il
courait y dorment là parce que les murs
il courait où il chassait de fonctions
humaines vrai sourit s'intéresse pas au
tibet dans le cerveau le truc qui fait
que tes muscles deviennent paralysait
fait les cheveux
vivait alors oui le compass qui dirait
des films the wall e puis sous un même
site soit avoir un fichier qui façonnent
skytg24 le côté jeu ma [ __ ] et met de
côté quand il se retourne comme pour moi
dans la rue comme se fait poursuivre par
une minute on peut on peut s'imaginer
que peut-être les relais des animaux
rejoue des comportements essentiels à la
survie s'alimenter se reproduire se
défendre attaquer et j'ai mangé dans
d'autres cas nous car c'est rob est
complexe plus vivant et plus complexe
c'est d'être hétéro nour el kareh près
nord-est et des rêves d'efforts tout ça
se passe mal on veut parler ça sort pas
d'un point discret 11 4
quelqu'un nous agressent les plus
fréquents ces agressions les thèmes du
système de fraikin peu importe à peu
près la culture loge plus les mêmes
thèmes qui reviennent se faire attaquer
blessés et hétéros sardi chez tout le
monde
je me dis moi que ça nous pratique à
faire face à l'adversité on le fait
comme on apprend ce qu'on nomme un
mémoire à long terme ce qu'on a pu
pendant journée on se pratique aussi
tout ça ça se passe dans un cerveau qui
coupé du monde extérieur par de tels
amusant de parler quelques minutes
empêche trop simulations ont été en
boucle fermée un petit peu on fait
abstraction du monde extérieur on ajoute
nos bébés là nous aurons notre mémoire
nous émotions nos souvenirs
contravention du peuple rêve
participants sont aussi des conseillers
de la pratique dans le fond c'est comme
ces rives telles situations dangereuses
ou deux semaines
mon cerveau il sait déjà que commence la
fin ça collait plus efficace je sais pas
ce qu'on tolère plus d'adversité
peut-être mais on est presque plus froid
face à soi on peut y faire face
cette diversité là donc je n'ai pas à
m'en plus rapide pour sortir ma
mitraillette puis la rsa mais je vais
peut-être par exemple plus plus me vols
soit plus capable de faire face à
quelqu'un qui ment en gueule vous
proposiez n'a par exemple je peux
m'imaginer feinte la passe et un
protocole pétrole puis je comprends
quelqu'un qui a pas de problème quelques
uns des problèmes jeunes vieux jeu terra
viva grande avancée par m toutefois
c'est très différent pour voir mais
c'est intéressant aussi
finalement la raison pour laquelle on
est paralysée c'est que sont les dépôts
l'on serait tel monstre nôtres quand
c'est flou c'est un trouble de sony bmg
j'ai des hommes à parts à 69 cents
dessins quand on voit des besoins chez
les hommes que chez les femmes on sait
pas pourquoi ils vont me mais leur rêve
ils vont vivre leur rêve qui vont sortir
du dit que vous êtes protégé bien
souvent les gens autour ou ata qui vont
voir se bat depuis vos factures de
gestes pendant la pause est en train de
rêver à tal afar votre raconté contre la
main somnambule ou ce qui est beaucoup
plus utile d'avoir un contenu lyon des
adultes peut se rappeler leur contenu
sont abaissées en début de nuit
ce genre de règles dont on parle sans
paralysie c'est en fait nuit
puis il faut compter un contenu s'est
passé telle affaire puis éliminé ça
qu'on sait pas exactement qu'est ce qui
se passe encore mais c'est pas très
longtemps qui s'est identifié une
vingtaine d'années à peine se prononce à
la prochaine grosse pomme on sait que
tête des régions qui nous paralyse
fonction des paradis des traitements qui
prennent pour heures pour contrôler ça
on comprend pas comment ce que ça mange
à base de pilules qui fêtait la fin vous
ça remarche là dessus c'est pas nos
connaissances de l'atonie musculaire çà
colpron comprend pas très bien puisque
je ne serai pas mal là dessus ça serait
dans certains cas un prédicteur de
dégénérescence de type parkinsoniens
mais des publications qui montre sorte
pour propre à l'ichec soit non plus la
spa tout le monde ça peut arriver c'est
plutôt le monde a levé le propre à la
convaincre de se protéger ça nous arrive
à tous moments
c'est quoi justement sur l'éthique 1
quand l'europe le temple l'oedème sont
tombés très bas il n'y a pas
d'explication py.g points 2/3 théorie
là-dessus
une des théories qui dit la phase
consiste donc à l'espace sur son dans
l'espace l'eau s'y connaît trois anneaux
dans les oreilles qui contient du
liquide
les trois anneaux où l'eau sont orientés
de façon différente ce qui est porté
manquant bouddha de tahiti le liquide
bout dans les anneaux il est celle là
dedans selon qui ce font bouger c'est
petit c'est de s'amuser ma tête est
passé tel endroit dans les trois axes x
qui récusait quand on est couché sur le
dos qu'on bouge plus le liquide
tomberait dans le fond de cet anneau la
courbe inférieur ça fait comme si on est
en train de tomber possibilité quand
j'étais tendu une classe de bord d'un
lac ça me fait perso puis quand je suis
debout depuis certains façon nous sommes
pas certains que ce soit sur d'autres
disent que c'est quand on au micro
détendit muscles ça fait comme un peu
comme un commutateur qui freinent
étincelles puis on passe quand on tombe
la pression pour le susurre sous l'eau
les pauvres protocole les pauvres de
recherche est reçue ces terres espère
vraiment des petits bidules pour ça on
n'a pas d'argent faire exhorte c'est une
question de la réponse parce que ce fait
est parfaite des docks là dessus
maintenant il faut s'attarder sauf que
ça fait de la question de ta passion le
taf intérêts chauffard passionné vous
êtes passionné je connais pas je sais
pas à quoi c'est dû
parlons de justement avant de terminer
la conversation parlons des pilules pour
dormir parce que dernièrement on entend
beaucoup parler d'eux c'est de prôner
serment des des pilules pharmaceutiques
mais on a entendu parler des méthodes
naturelles fait que mélatonine cbd
toutes ces choses là pour aider au
sommeil
qu'en est il de ces choses là ce que
c'est positif est ce que c'est des trucs
qu'on peut implémenté dans notre vie
comment ça fonctionne il ya deux mix
différent dans ce que la mélatonine une
ce point sommes différents mais tony
norman donc on génère naturellement oui
puis qui montre un pic en milieu de nuit
à peu près mais qui commence à décrocher
commence à monter
en fin de soirée début de nuit
commencent à monter quand on a enfreint
par la boj la méthode extérieur on
renforce signalons la croiser dans les
bonnes conditions ça va marcher par la
mélatonine seul ça marche pas si bien
que ça mais si tu prends le fameux 30
minutes de détente inverse d'activité
que tous les signaux sont convergents de
tonnes décida de biologie quelqu'un
m'aide à tenir c'est l'environnemental
signal comportementale le savons tous
dans le même sens ne s'appelait pas mal
aidé la mélatonine vraiment un ajout
significatif dans ces colonnes pour bien
fonctionner sa tête mais la table le
premier dormir s'est dit auscitains
d'éveil d'un couteau passagers tués pour
un petit but au tableau
ça devrait fonctionner puisqu'il est ce
que le corps développe une résistance à
cenon semble pas que j'ai fait une
oblitération scientifiques déjà là
dessus nous faisions des écrits puis
c'est un repas de paul on pensait se
refaire dès la puberté parce que ce
genre de choses ça sert aussi au
changement des saisons changement de
gaza sens de la lumière pourrait faire
changer la couleur du pelage des animaux
pour qu'ils vainquent au printemps tout
ça pour moi c'est que ça modifierait le
développement sexuel des dix enfants
vers la naissance pour pas du tout je
n'avais pas de coutume en kz physique
entre rapport de dépendance physique
biologique
les gens vont peut-être voir pas ni
d'eau de plus en plus gras mais c'est
plus une dépendance psychologique ans
tandis pense que j'en prends toujours
mieux dormir là que non ce n'était pas
la bonne pilule bien des têtes qu'on a
tous le montant que les maisons soient
aussi vous donner la marche pas on va
prendre plus d puis par une sorte ce
n'est pas une méthode de prendre donc
avec sunny 6 ans les autres j'ai entendu
juste pour voir la lettonie
j'ai entendu que c'était surtout
efficace ou six ans fait efficace en cas
de décalage horaire ne permettant que
c'est une autre une autre utilisation
trop décale on va s'aimer l'interné pour
redonner leur à notre horloge produits
l'année commence à monter maintenant
c'est pour peut le faire quelques jours
avant de partir si je m'envole puis
décale de cinq heures mais je vais
prendre mais maintenant cinq heures
avant deux parties puissent avoir
commencé en train et puis en général au
pmu sur des quais le silure dur quoi
donc taper comme changement d'arrêt
d'autant de représentants
tout commence à prendre ton repos à la
prochaine heure si on avance dans des
cas les toners du souper soin d'éviter
d'être où je me sens très sensée bientôt
tu peux te dire que les détenus ne suis
pas nécessaire je parle des joueurs
déposera donc amasser un donneur
d'ordres déjà pour la les autres
médicaments qu'on prend des pilules
pilule on va passer par là on se rabat
est la quantité d'informations qui monte
au cerveau
donc ça nous permet de se détacher de
sape de ménager le calme des produits
naturels
cbd par exemple ben ça fabuleux mais je
serai anxiolytiques sans appel d'être
anxieux s'abaisse l'éveil
c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on peut
comprendre de sont ils pas beaucoup de
dire atur sur le cbd du sommeil
il y en avait un peu sur la tf c'est un
peu sur la marijuana en général prix de
différentes façons d dawesar très
variables le cbd ça commence un peu à
voir des études beaucoup chez l'animal
parc avons fait des couples aux réponses
de khat est ce qu'on commence à avoir
des effets indésirables quand est ce que
vous avez fait chez lui mais ça commence
tranquillement à la voix séparemment le
même genre de mais qu'est-ce que ça
déteint ça permet ou celle de sam et de
s'installer parce qu'un d'éveil et pas
aux aguets puis pour un vigile total
donc ils prennent si ça casse un peu
près jamais s'installe
ça veut dire est projeté s'avère aussi
comme anxiolytique besson n'en prenez
pas en danger par exemple très peu de
l'irad sud à croire les pros du national
en général faut faire attention aussi d
autres types de la verveine jones un
récit de vie sa valeur votre certain que
ça intéresse pas toujours de médicaments
qu'on peut prendre ou que ça prend un
effet et des érables par ailleurs il ya
des meilleures personnes qui peuvent
répondre à ça c'est des pharmacies des
médecins et les pharmaciens ou des
infirmières il faut santé des choses qui
devraient pour le savoir puis sait-on
jamais vous voudrez plus temple de
l'hégémonie faire de recherches puis
vous pouvez vous leur répondre et son
mais c'est surtout qu'ils ont un
commerce pour soi ainsi sur les dangers
y est là c'est ça n'est pas de quoi sur
le marché puis parce que les gens aux
fins de son en même temps on devrait
connaître soi même il faut qu'il ait
rendu cours parce qu'on est mal pris
parce que on était samedi
on voudrait le rallonger bien sûr on
parle tellement beaucoup de perte de
sommeil pour parle jamais de ceux qui
donc trop de problèmes récents
changements pour beaucoup puis quelqu'un
qui est insomniaque mais est ce que
c'est un recours ce qui m'attend un
médecin vous prescrit
des médicaments pour dormir ou c'est pas
une avenue qui soit à rouiba thing
quelqu'un qui dort mais je fais des
insomnies parce qu'il ya perdu son
conjoint au party fun ça y est tous
parce qu'il ya mal au parc accueille
l'événement vraiment désagréable on m'a
dit que des toits et c soit
psychologiquement ou physiquement
on va donner le médicament qu'il faut
pour b6 c'est à ces affaires là puis on
vous rend disponible la personne d'un
traitement autres on n'en déplaise aux
débuts des méthodes de dpu pour moi
c'est argent sont disponibles et très
bien montrer maintenant littérature
qu'est ce que depuis peu à ses apports
sont plus comportementale bon jeu
pendant encore une fois on a expulsé dès
ce mondial du sommeil et au québec et à
québec le québec charles morel qui allie
qui est super bien fait c'est de kane
est pas mal la question que montré
maintes fois que nous projeter plus
comportementale vont avoir des effets
plus longtemps qui est donc préféré donc
je peux partir quelqu'un que telle pour
les dons y parvenir avec disponibles
pour faire un traitement comportemental
qui quand même est plus exigeant qui
demande la personne tu te bats pour
avoir à faire face à deux ou trois
petits problèmes que toi pour toujours
des deux oreilles cédé juste besoin
d'être croyant que d'habitude et hétéros
ça fonctionne ça s'adresse tout le monde
tape it a pas de sauveur se passe même
je t'envoie l'auberge où aucun au
camping du try to de capacité de faire
sur les confins de relaxation alors que
tous les bouchons ça va mal c'est la
relaxation tu pars avec l'étape en fait
une thérapie comportementale ou
cognitive comportementale fois suis avec
toi dans ce le médecin et fabien je
parle de traiter avec avec des pilotes
mais au bout de trois mois ça commence à
faire un peu si je mets moi j'avais des
crous douleurs à l'estomac quand vous
trouverons moi j'ai encore besoin des
plus beaux j'ai mal est à moi me poser
des questions c'est quoi cette affaire
est un problème à régler l'une en pyjama
4-1 disparu dès le premier mois j'étais
libre à savoir puisque c'est comme ça on
pourrait sauver ça doit être pareil
ah ben c'est pas le problème s'est posé
sa main et puisque le bruit dans la tête
ça va au sol
il était un portrait cinq premiers
réglages puis ça passe de plus en plus
les médecins peuvent faire la thérapie
certains médecins peuvent intégrer une
fois de thérapie peut pas reprendre ses
méthodes aussi
puis après une psychologue peuvent le
faire
traverso des producteurs qui sont qu'ils
sont cons droit de pratiquer d'être la
thérapie qui peuvent très bien faire ce
travail dominical
ça doit plus longtemps un an plus tard
la pilule bellay faut monter de la dose
puis soit alors que comportemental on
peut laisser bones the beats audio comme
le reste des fois par tomber dans le
panneau
la pomme steve jobs sur canal oui on
parlait de thc tantôt où en sont les
études sur ce qu'est ce que ça dit elle
et par rapport aux sommets qui achètent
plus hallucinogènes fait que par rapport
aux chats mais ça peut être perturbant
ça n'est pas des personnes qui a pas
d'étude de il ya des études un peu mais
qui compte robbie le dosage qui sur
président de soleil il y en a eu il y en
a moins de diass avons plutôt subi des
menaces parce qu'ils demandent que je
connais qui fume une prof de deux potes
avant d'aller se coucher puis ça leur
permet de juste partir c'est parce que
penser à aider de d'apparaître
ok ouais c'est ça tu peux quatre fois
est-ce qu d'ici là je peux choisir plus
haut à th est au plus bas ces bd j'ai un
couple d'amis moi qui en a un des deux
qui prennent plus le 21 h et ou de
propyle lv1 cbd qui dessinera choisi
puisque des besoins j'éjecté justement
le même monsieur matthew walker qui
parlait de ce pilier lui recommandait
pas vraiment l' usage de soi alcool ou
drogue pour pour annuler sa méprise même
ça peut t'aider à t'endormir n'aurait
pas nécessairement la qualité une
qualité sommeil l'alcool c'est ça c'est
ça peut ça fait un peu plus aux amateurs
de mettre un peu plus calme puis le
sommeil voire exclusive de sommeil ils
vont venir pour pas t'endormir mais
après ça perturbe la régulation des
températures déjà plus de mouvement tout
chaud sur un tapis de course marc été
renforcée par non c'est pas du tout une
bonne idée ça être pas du tout de suite
vous avez parlé on effleuré plusieurs
fois si vous avez dit
et on parle beaucoup des effets de
passer dormir mais très peu de trop
dormir c'est quoi le flamand le négatif
de trop dormait l'étude épidémiologique
déductions faites pas des personnages et
beaucoup de monde vont montrer qu'avec
ma des gens qui dorment plus longtemps
ont un risque de mortalité relative
aussi élevés que ceux qui dorment peu
vaccinés ça nous dit que ce pont de peu
dormi ou de trop dormir s'était pas
dormir le bon tant pis s'il est vrai en
tout ce qui est biologique puisque le
succès d' équilibre l'équilibré des
énergies ont été enterrés mais l'
équilibre des forces qui sont alors on
parle l'inflammation tu as des produits
en cfa mais toi tu es des produits pro
inflammatoires c'est l'équipe de ce que
françois qu'on le devient contre les
agressions sauf c'est vrai dans tous on
veut un peu de stress pas trop de stress
tel équilibre se nourrir c'est ça c'est
vrai pour tous mais jamais réparer puis
quand on perturbe sort on rompt
l'équilibré puis le fonctionnement
devient plus adapté enfin qu'il faut que
tu donnes le nombre d'heures dont on a
besoin pour fonctionner comme il faut
pas dans journée qu'on parle pas
beaucoup des gens qui dorment trop parce
que peu de médicaments pour ça
puisqu'ils sont les médias mais qu'est
ce qu'on reçoit son légiférer pas mal de
solides le slip secoue stimulant des
speed c'est une autre histoire sont les
personnes qui se plaignent de trop
dormir
sinon quand c'est mal vu qu'on se
traiter de père a subi sa nuit notre
fonctionnement dionne comme succès aux
dix personnes malades chroniques
difficiles
ce qui saute de narcolepsie ou dans
cette forme de dépressions des gens qui
donnent beaucoup beaucoup du ballon rond
va aller voir un peu qu'est ce qui
s'passe infections en général on veut
traiter des deux retraités troubles de
sommeil puis le trouble de santé mentale
en même temps il ne faut pas prendre
position qu'un cause l'autre sinon on va
passer à côté sont dit on se croit de
sommeil après faut bien gérer son
anxiété ça allait mieux après ce pauvre
et on les chefs de montres 35 % des gens
dont la dépression voit bien d'hommes
encore mal ces deux choses qui se
produisent pour tester une roue en fait
c'est un amour il aussi normal très plus
anxieux puis - faisant qu'ils ont eu
toutes ces deux choses c'est ceux qui se
promènent fait que tous les deux qu'on
parle pas beaucoup des gens qui donnent
trop qui d'entre eux qui donnent
beaucoup
park on parle pas de einstein domaine
avoir 9h30 par nuit fais pas trop il
doit mais beaucoup je faisais du s'y est
dit ou écrit dix athlètes souvent de
haut niveau vont dormir plus qu'elle est
moins de moins de gens j'ai encore en
fin de semaine je peux dans le journal
quelqu'un disait qu'ils dormaient
beaucoup c'est un athlète de pointe
cloche pied qu'il a piqué qui dormait
quand même beaucoup
ça dépend des jamais chez les athlètes
c'est différent aussi les athlètes
qu'ils arrêtent de s'entraîner par
exemple dans moins bien il faut que ça
en train de s'entraîner ça c'est
l'absence d'entraînement alors quelqu'un
qui habite celui qui s'entraîne va mal
dormi parce que votre droit mal un peu
partout d'une part puis pas que je vois
cette dépense d'énergie à ce moment là
c'est un moment où est-ce qu'on le fait
de tout ce qu'elles ont dit qu'ils aient
de répartition comme l'alimentation
comme tout
ouais c'est ça de ce que je retiens la
conversation s'est dit on parle beaucoup
aujourd'hui d'alimentation intuitive le
stade heures de suivre c'est son appétit
cibles sont j'imagine qu'elle se met un
peu la même chose de suivre comprendre
il ya des gens qui vont vers sow qui
trouve de vrais dormait quand ça vous
tente
puis ses premiers intéressés d'experts
qu'il est juste de terminer une
vingtaine de personnes qui se sont tirés
une caverne en france
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai ce serait
tellement devant les cristaux de soude
et des jeux des petits prix avec des
jeux un chercheur français qu'il avait
fait le même chiffre
je sais que qui de l'oeuf est aussi
celui qui a décroché mais paradoxalement
il a fait ça dans quatre mammouth qu'est
ce que ça ferait même chose ici me navre
ceux qui disséminent à une caverne sans
soleil puis la lui dormait puisse
réveiller quand ils voulaient puis
c'était pas un succès c'est deux mois
qui restent là assez longtemps
après comme 35 jours ils sont à lui
pensé que ça peut être calculé ces
journées je pense que ça faisait 35
jours puis l'ont sorti peu comme lui
lance en tête ça faisait la moitié du
temps ces sept produits encore dans les
glaces qui va de soi s'il est déterminé
avantage qui fait ce n'est pas parce
qu'il est supposé quitte à plusieurs
personnes - à toute espèce social aussi
lui qui met tous de bourque est
nécessaire pour qu'ils se rendent compte
que le temps ait à passer par ces
fictions après 37 jours déjà parce que
vous avez toujours que tel grand
et on va en prendre beaucoup de soin
parce que les spéciales à d'acheteurs
facile à gérer 23 faire face quand il
voulait dans mais quand il voulait bien
le dirigeant ou à peu près d'ailleurs la
seule chose c'est que c'était assez
frais il faisait plus froid que penser
parce qu il fera 15 faisait pas prêt à
11 degrés j'ai compris la 13e mètre 95 %
du missile est parfois plus que si tu
renversé de luz tonton duvet n'ont
jamais le temps que tous ces petits bugs
l'homme mais c'est pas grave je voulais
pas faire quelque chose de mieux
contrôler un petit peu parce que défense
contrôle trop campait la nature de
s'exprimer qui arrive à l'intempérance à
aucune des situations froide
voici ce qui s'est passé et nous
fournira des 40 jours on verra bien mais
quand tu es trop contrôlé dessus après
un essai de s'exprimer là tu peux pas
dire clairement c'est l'heure de votre
iphone
la sellette de pleurer c'est peu pour
faire sauf que de sauver des diètes et 8
c est un peu ça aussi
puis prendre le saviez qu'à se placer
par soi même si ces deux voies comme ce
que ça va donner puis biens et des
personnes mais c'est surtout l'équilibré
saut on a dormi de conte à dormir
moi je mets jamais de cadrage matin
jamais quai puis merveille c'est pas que
je peux prêter mon réveil espace
histoire lol mais je dors ce que j'ai
besoin de dormir ça que je me couche
fatigué je me dope je me couche plus de
bonheur puis vous aimerez valeurs qu'il
faut dix soit 6 5 heures du matin des
voix 6h30 du matin je fais mais a failli
ne sait jamais trop où temps je pose
problème tant mieux mais si jamais trop
tard donc six brevets cinq heures j'ai
dormi huit heures quand même beaucoup
pour moi je commence ma journée je fais
mes enfants que c'est qu'un répit le
lendemain ça va être autre chose ça
fonctionne assez bien ce qu'il fallait
avoir un cadran j'imagine qu'on peut
s'appeler nous réveiller dans un cycle
de sommeil qui était pas du tout naturel
puis un petit peu les chansons que que
soit de faire réveiller pendant sommeil
paradoxal parce que l'état n'est pas de
ça mais par exemple la fin du jeu
quarante minutes parfois 50 pistes assez
long les gens s'arrêtent dedans sont
assez élevés ont depuis sommeil lent
profond ou vraiment fait nuit normal ça
que ce travail repos quant à mal un
vaste parc victoria beckham ce monde
comme ça et en début de nuit
je suis pas trop grave il faut des
gadgets qui ont aussi des gadgets qui
détecte les mouvements du zouk travail
par un sommeil paradoxal pirates et des
rêves peuvent pas toujours très très
bien pourquoi mais ça marche pas très
bien on peut supposer que naturellement
se réveiller juste qu'on a assez dormir
et cela
c'est ce que je sais ce que je fais
c'est sans doute pondérée par une
brigade de gignac
j'aimerais du tout parce que de la
lumière qui nous ont pas de rire nos
peaux de rideau on entend des faits tous
ceux qui ont envie du bruit le cds 5 ans
s'est voulu laisser surprendre même
semaine
bell est la cdc des cardinaux puis les
corneilles puis les maires ou d'admirer
en pis c'est un voisin claque la porte
de sa voiture dont gpat un mécanicien
automobile alan tôt puis j'ai pas de
magnac décideront de mon site du matin
mais c'est un des toitures c'était du
pavage puissent assister sénat moi ça me
dérange pas trop facile naturellement
aussi diffuser l'humain avant qu'on ait
des maisons des rides ou dessus on était
beaucoup plus régi par le 6e temps des
cavernes
puis il devait ce bloc est ce que
j'imagine pascal phone faire jouer
solide en face la macanita qui devait
sur les élections dans mes plus
longtemps dans mes par plusieurs
périodes ses sbires je suis peut-être
plus tôt on peut remonter au temps de la
colonie du comminges à fonctionner le
ont peut-être la voie qui était le
notaire notarié son activité 6 heures du
matin qui ne fait rien de mal à ça on
peut savoir un petit peu mais quand on
dit on dort tendeur de moins qu'il ya
cinq ans et d évidence un peu mais des
fois je tombe des nues culture bâtie
tomber certains groupes sphère faut
faire beaucoup d'évidence convergence
des évidences et ceux qui ne donnent
plus de plus de conviction plus merci
infiniment fait plaisir c'est un réel
plaisir je vais passer s'est endormi à
temps très court termiste jeter un coup
d'oeil jeté coup d'état comme c'est
facile ou est-ce que vous est ce que les
gens peuvent suivre les recherches qui
se font aux excuses on peut aller voir
ces choses de l'yonne il ya eu cet
américain mais peut contaminer je pense
par district
je pense que j'avais une attitude
national des chefs ils font chaney est
saccadé un sondage à des milliers de
personnes sur qu'elle avoue que j'ai lu
trop question seulement ça c'est
intéressant de voir ce que les sens là
dessus sinon quel est ce que le site
normand là-dessus point sa famille
dormait là dessus canada.ca normale ce
qui est dépensé slip on est coincé à pas
mal de matériel là dessus y compris près
pandémie des trucs à faire seul on le
nourrit pas mal la prime ce projet un
peu mais des campagnes qui seront pis
cet organisme l'eau s'est joint à la
société caennais d'une sommeil qui est
un regroupement de chercheurs le tuer
autant les organisations pour la
population puis des chargeurs qui vont
travailler plus prochain ensemble je
suis super super bien il ya son et puis
sinon on va essayer de voir ce qui se
passe dans un champ google ou chaumeil
mais il ya toutes sortes de choses c'est
une béquille du meilleur sinon c'est
d'éviter des gens qui travaillent dessus
exergue exactement parfait merci des
coûts maîtrisés
merci d'avoir écouté ses podcasts
jusqu'à la fin de ce père que vous avez
apprécié les conversations ça prouve que
vous êtes de réelles fans de
conversation et du sans-fil pas de
casser on vous remercie vraiment
beaucoup
si vous voulez avoir plus de contenus
plus de conversation c'est sûr
pétillante que ça se passe hier sur
petra non seulement on met tous les
podcasts en ligne au moment où est ce qu
on les tourne donc on a beaucoup de
semaine d'avant sur le pétrole mais on
fait aussi des encore moins de filtres
qui sont exclusifs aux mômes pétrole
risque on parle d'homme nicole et moi de
la conversation qu'ont bien d'avoir ce
qu'on met un peu plus en profondeur dans
certains sujets complets abordés ou
qu'on abordait pas mal podcast donc
allez sur notre page rituel mais le lien
vers sa voix dans la description du
podcast qui remercie encore une fois de
nous avons écouté jusqu'à la fonte